Zwischen einem Zehntel und einem Fünftel der deutschen Bevölkerung sind antisemitisch eingestellt. Beim israelbezogenen Antisemitismus sind es sogar fast 40 Prozent. Das sind viel zu viele.
Es ist nicht normal, dass man sich irgendwie Gedanken machen muss, ob man sein Kind zum Fußball schicken kann. Das ist überhaupt nicht normal. Man sollte die Kinder ohne Probleme schicken können und man sollte überhaupt nicht als Eltern darüber nachdenken können, ob die sicher sind und die sollten auch nicht bei Spielen angepöbelt werden oder irgendwas.
Wenn man die Chronologie sieht, was gepostet wurde von dem Spieler, der eine immense Reichweite in Social Media hat und wenn man das sieht, was der FC Bayern nach einem Gespräch als Erklärung abgegeben hat, um den Spieler ohne jegliche Konsequenzen weiter im Verein spielen zu lassen, ist für mich, ist für jeden, der unsere Gesellschaft auch nur annähernd respektiert, absolut indiskutabel und inakzeptabel.
Ich glaube ursprünglich war der Fußball mehr das Problem. Inzwischen ist der Fußball ein ganz erheblichen Teil einer Lösungsmöglichkeit des Problems.
Das waren verschiedene Zitate, die wir da gehört haben, aus unterschiedlichen journalistischen Formaten. Zum einen aus einer längeren Reportage des Deutschlandfunk, haben wir einmal Felix Klein gehört, dem Beauftragten der Bundesregierung für jüdisches Leben und Kampf gegen Antisemitismus. Wir haben ebenfalls Joseph Schuster gehört, den Vorsitzenden des Zentralrats der Juden. Alon Maier, das ist der Vorsitzende von Maccabi Deutschland. Das wiederum war aus dem aktuellen Sportstudio. Und wir haben noch eine Mutter gehört, die eben ihr Kind bei einem Verein, der zu Maccabi Deutschland gehört, zum Fußballspiel geschickt hat. Das wiederum kommt aus einer Reportage des Hessischen Rundfunks. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und auf Blue Sky. Und ich freue mich, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt zu einem sehr wichtigen Thema. Ihr habt es ja an der Episodenschreibung schon gesehen. Und ich freue mich umso mehr, dass ich mit Felix Tamsut einen ganz hervorragenden Gesprächspartner dafür bekommen habe. Felix, ich freue mich sehr, dass du hier bist und dass du dir die Zeit nimmst für dieses Gespräch.
Hi. Hi Max, freut mich sehr, hier zu sein. Ich freue mich auf die Folge und bin auch großer Fan von dir, von deiner Arbeit. Deswegen ist das umso erfreulicher, von mir mit dabei zu sein. Selbst, wenn die Umstände nicht unbedingt so glücklich sind.
Der Anlass ist beschissen, das Thema ist komplex. Ich sage es einfach, wie es ist.
Auf jeden Fall.
Es ist sehr schwierig. Also vielen, vielen Dank, dass du hier bist. Danke für die Lorbeeren. Ich habe mir auch vorgenommen, gerade herauszusprechen in dieser Sendung. Deswegen habe ich jetzt auch gerade schon gesagt, wie ätzend die Situation ist. Ich hoffe, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen, das ist jetzt eine kleine Präambel, die ich vorausschicken will, dass ihr uns beiden einfach empathisch begegnet, auch was unsere Wortwahl angeht. Denn man liegt so leicht daneben, man formuliert falsch, man verrennt sich in rhetorischen Sackgassen. Bitte unterstellt uns das Gute und nicht das Schlechte. Reiß Dinge nicht aus dem Kontext. Und wenn wir aber Quatsch gelabert haben, dann gebt uns bitte konstruktives Feedback. Damit können wir beide ja sehr gut umgehen. Aber darauf setze ich einfach und dementsprechend möchte ich nämlich auch versuchen, hier möglichst klar zu formulieren, weil nur weil das Thema komplex ist und das Thema gerade auch ein heißes Eisen ist, in dem Sinne, dass eine Polarisierung in allen Ecken der Gesellschaft stattfindet, muss man die Dinge trotzdem klar benennen dürfen. Ansonsten hat die Polarisierung schon ihr erstes Schlechtes bewirkt, nämlich dass wir über die Themen gar nicht mehr ordentlich sprechen können. Der Diskurs eher ist nötig. Und zu diesem Diskurs gehört auch der kurze Hinweis, dass der Rasenfunk allein crowdfinanziert ist. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrt ihr alles, was dazu zu wissen ist. Aber das ist in dieser Sendung wirklich nicht so wichtig. Wir wollen heute sprechen über den Nahostkonflikt, über den Krieg zwischen Israel und Palästina, über den Terrorangriff der Hamas am 7. Oktober. Und wir wollen damit mit einem besonderen Gast darüber sprechen, nämlich mit Felix Tamsut. Und ich dachte, Felix, am Anfang reden wir vielleicht nochmal kurz über dich, denn wusstest du eigentlich, vielleicht hast du das schon immer gemerkt, wenn wir miteinander Kontakt hatten, wusstest du, dass uns ein fast heiliges Band verbindet? Du bist der Sohn eines Rabbis, du hast, ich glaube, fünf Geschwister, wenn ich es mir richtig gemerkt habe. Ich bin der Sohn von zwei Pfarrern, logischerweise evangelisch, sonst könnte ich da nicht so offen drüber sprechen. Und habe drei Geschwister. Ist dir das schon aufgefallen, dass wir quasi der Glaube und den, den wir in unserem Umfeld erlebt haben, der hat uns offenbar zusammengebracht?
Nein, das wusste ich nicht. Das ist ein interessantes Funfact, um die Folge anzufangen. Aber ja, umso interessanter wird unser Gespräch sein. Vielleicht schaffen wir die Brücke zwischen den Religionen, die seit 2000 Jahren nicht geschaffen worden ist. Wer weiß, wer weiß.
Aber geht dir das auch so, dass du immer wieder mit Menschen zusammenkommst, wo sich dann rausstellt, ach, deine Eltern sind auch so. Bei mir sind es eben meistens Pfarrer, andere Evangelische. Hast du das auch bei dir?
Ich sag mal so, als ich in Israel war, schon hier eher weniger, weil ich glaube, das hat eher mit meinen Kreisen zu tun, also mit meinen Freundeskreisen, mit meinen Freundinnenkreisen, und es hat eher damit zu tun, dass ich eher in eher, ich sag mal, eher linken Kreisen bewege. Und das ist wahrscheinlich das erste Mal, dass es mir passiert, Max.
Das ist ja verrückt, denn mir begegnen ständig irgendwelche anderen Pfarrers, Kinder oder auch Pfarrer. Ich grüße alle, die den Rasenfunk hören. Davon weiß ich nämlich auch, dass es einige gibt. Das ist jetzt ein Bereich, der ist sehr privat. Wenn du nicht drüber reden willst, alles gut, dann sag's bitte einfach. Aber wie hat dich denn das geprägt, in einem Haushalt aufzuwachsen, in dem Glauben dann ebenso eine wichtige Rolle spielt?
Ich sag mal so, also es war auf jeden Fall eine Erfahrung. Ich glaube, man muss, ich sag mal so, man hat manchmal die Vorstellung von ultraorthodoxen jüdischen Familien, als ob alles so streng ist und die ultraorthodoxe Welt ist ein bisschen komplexer als das und ein bisschen vielfältiger als das. Ich komme zum Beispiel aus der, ich bin nordafrikanischer Herkunft und da ist die Ultraorthodoxie eher, ich sag mal, flexibler, ich sag mal so, wir sind fünf Geschwister, wir sind teils nicht mehr religiös, teils so halb, teils immer noch sehr streng orthodox und wir kommen miteinander klar, also es war nie Thema, so nach dem Motto, du bist nicht mehr religiös, du bist nicht mehr mein Kind oder so, sondern mein Vater hat uns immer beigebracht, dass die Familie und der Zusammenhalt in der Familie immer zuerst kommt und im Endeffekt ist es so im Judentum, dass man ab dem Alter 13 für Jungen und 12 für Mädchen für die eigenen Taten verantwortlich ist und deswegen hat mein Vater mir persönlich und auch meinen Geschwistern immer gesagt, im Endeffekt werdet ihr euren Weg finden müssen. Ich kann nur sagen, was ich für gut finde, aber im Endeffekt werdet ihr euren Weg finden müssen. Ich habe meins gefunden. Ich bin immer noch in sehr, sehr guten Kontakten mit meiner Familie, mit meinem Vater, mit meinen Geschwistern. Wir sind sehr eng beieinander und ich glaube, das ist wichtiger als Religion und als alles, obwohl ich sage mal, die politischen Diskussionen manchmal schon interessant sind, aber sonst ist das wirklich eine Freude für mich, Teil dieser Familie zu sein und I wouldn't have it any other way, wie man auf Englisch sagt.
Ja, also das geht mir ganz ähnlich. Ich habe zum Glück auch ein sehr gutes Verhältnis zu allen meinen Brüdern. Ich habe drei Brüder und auch zu meinen Eltern. Aber jetzt, als du gerade gesagt hast, mit 13 bzw. mit 12, das ist dann die Bar Mitzvah oder wie heißt das bei den Mädchen nochmal? Bad Mitzvah, genau. Das finde ich insofern interessant, weil das genau das Alter ist, wo zumindest ich am härtesten rebelliert habe, gegen alles, was mit Religion zu tun hatte. Eigentlich ja interessant. Ich weiß nicht, ob es bei dir ähnlich war, aber ich war da ganz in der überheblichen, also ich war so ein ganz Naturalist, Atheist, habe gesagt, ja, kommen ihr mit eurem, klar, Gott und sieben Tage und so weiter, das ist alles Evolution und hört mir doch auf und war da voll auf dem Darwin-Trip, um das mal so zu sagen.
Ja, nee, also ich glaube, diese rebellistische Phase hat bei mir schon früher angefangen. Ich erinnere mich an eine Situation, wo ich bei einem Burger-Laden war als Kind, ich war fünf oder sechs oder was weiß ich, und der Burger-Laden war nicht kosher. Und meine Tante hat uns trotzdem hingenommen, weil wir, ich und meine Schwester, das sehr, sehr wollten als Kinder Hamburger, manchmal esse ich kein Fleisch, aber damals war es noch ein Ding. Und mein Vater hat das sehr herausgefunden und hat aus der Situation herausgefragt, warum wir es so wollten, in einem nicht kosheren Laden zu essen. Wir haben gesagt, na ja, Hamburger, wir sind Kinder, wir mögen Burger, wir mögen Chips, wir mögen Cola, ist eigentlich nicht so schwer. Und dann kam die Frage, aber was hättet ihr gemacht, wenn der Fleisch hit, was weiß ich, Schweinefleisch isst? Und ich habe gesagt, na ja, ich hätte es trotzdem gegessen, das ist ein Hamburger, was von Nutzer Schiedet das macht. Und das war nicht unbedingt eine Antwort, die man von einem Sexuellen erwartet. Ich habe mich tatsächlich sehr früh mit der Idee einer Religion und mit diesem, ja, Geburtssystem beschäftigt und tatsächlich, als ich zu dem Ergebnis kam, dass ich das Ganze eher kritisch sehe, war die Reaktion meines Vaters eher, ich bin hier, ich bin dein Vater, ich werde dich unterstützen, egal wie du dich entscheidest. Und es hat dazu geführt, dass ich schon einige Elemente aus der Religion immer noch mit mir trage. Also ich kann nicht sagen, dass ich die jüdische Religion ablehne, obwohl ich es schon wichtig halte, die problematischen Teile zu kritisieren. Und das tue ich wirklich jeden Tag und in jeder Möglichkeit, die mir gegeben wird. Aber es gibt schon Sachen, die mir Kraft geben und die mir helfen, sei es in Sachen mentale Gesundheit und in anderen Bereichen, als ich eine starke, leider schlechte posttraumatische Phase hatte, haben mir diese religiösen Prinzipien sehr geholfen und ein paar, ich sage mal, ankern aus der Religion. Und auch das muss man sagen, auch das ist ein Element dieses ganzen Systems.
Ja, daher kommen ja wahrscheinlich die Religionen. Wir haben die Religion irgendwann mal gebraucht, damit wir uns nicht gegenseitig unzivilisiert auf den Kopf schlagen. Machen wir natürlich trotzdem. Aber es wurde alles ein bisschen in Bahnen gelenkt. Und das ist ja das Interessante, dass über alle Weltreligionen hinweg die gewissen Grundprinzipien, du sollst dich gegenseitig nicht umbringen, du sollst nicht klauen. Und ich bin übrigens der einzige Gott, an den du glauben sollst. Das ist bei fast allen Weltreligionen ungefähr gleich. Anscheinend hat das der Mensch einfach gebraucht. Aber ich finde das halt insofern interessant. Und deswegen fand ich das jetzt auch angemessen damit einzusteigen, weil das nicht nur eine biografische Parallele zwischen uns ist, sondern weil ja auch einfach dieser Konflikt auch deshalb, glaube ich, so unauflösbar erscheint, weil er in letzter Konsequenz bei einigen Menschen tief in Religion mündet und damit in etwas, was höchst subjektiv ist, bei aller Objektivität, die die Religion sich geben möchte. Aber es bleibt etwas Subjektives, wie ich eine Religion auslebe und interpretiere, wie ich den Koran, die Bibel oder die Thora lese. Das liegt in mir selbst angelegt. Und zum anderen, weil es aber auch etwas Absolutes ist und etwas unverrückbar. Und gleichzeitig auch etwas, was Menschen unheimlich wichtig sein kann. Nach dem, was du erzählt hast, glaube ich, wir nehmen Religion ungefähr ähnlich ernst. Wir wissen, dass es gute Seiten gibt. Wir sehen aber auch sehr viel Schlechtes darin. Und darüber habe ich sehr viel nachgedacht. Aber ehrlich gesagt, sind das keine positiven Gedanken gewesen, weil dann kommt man auf eine Jahrtausendalte-Geschichte, die immer damit zu tun hat, dass sich Anhänger verschiedene Religionen in Kriege begeben haben, in scheinbar unauflösbare Konflikte. Hast du da Gedanken zu?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich glaube, deine Analyse ist auf jeden Fall richtig. Und ich sage es ja immer, also in jedem Konflikt, die es in mir gibt zwischen einer religiösen Idee und einer Idee, die ich menschlich richtig und wichtig finde, wird die menschliche Seite immer besiegen. Und das finde ich am wichtigsten. Wenn es für jemanden wichtiger ist, eher mit der religiösen Teil zufrieden zu sein und nicht mit dem, ich sage mal, logischen menschlichen Teil, da fängt das Problem an im Prinzip. Ich glaube schon, dass die jüdische Religion manche Mechanismen hat, um das zu verhindern. Leider gibt es trotzdem Elemente in der israelischen, auch jüdischen Gesellschaft, die das nicht so ernst nehmen oder ignorieren. Aber das ist trotzdem Thema. Ich finde schon, dass es manchmal diese Clashes gibt zwischen den zwei Ideen. Und es ist meiner Meinung nach ganz entscheidend, wie man mit diesen Clashes umgeht und mit welchen Entscheidungen man sich trifft. Ich finde es für mich auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig, diese kritische Seite oder die problematische Seite der Religion, also meiner Religion, des Judenzums besser zu verstehen und die ganze Zeit kritisieren zu können, auch aus einer Position von Wissen. Wie gesagt, da hilft mir meine Position als Sohn eines Rabbis, als ehemaliger Yeshiva-Student. Also Yeshiva ist eine religiöse Schule, eine sehr strenge religiöse Schule. Und wenn man aus einer Position von Wissen kommt, ist das wirklich sehr schwierig, auch was dagegen zu sagen. Weil diese Meinungen, die man spezifisch über das Judentum hat, finde ich hier in Deutschland, die sind manchmal schlecht begründet, bis zu nicht begründet, bis zu nicht gut begründet. Und deswegen ist es wichtig, tatsächlich mit Wissen damit, um unvorzugehen und ich würde mir wünschen, dass auch Menschen in anderen Kreisen und anderen Religionen und anderen generell Kreisen, wo die Idee dahinter oder der Glaube dahinter tatsächlich von innen kommt und nicht vom Kopf, sondern eher vom Herzen. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass mehr Menschen das auch sehen, dass es manchmal auch wichtig ist, diese Reflektion zu haben und zu verstehen. Die Theorie sagt mir, das und das und das zu tun oder so und so und so zu denken, aber das halte ich für nicht richtig. Das halte ich für problematisch und das würde viele unserer Probleme lösen auf dieser Welt, glaube ich.
Was glaubst du denn, was so die größten Vorurteile gegenüber dem Judentum sind in Deutschland? Ich habe ja gesagt, ich will auch an die heißen Eisen ran.
Ja, alles gut, alles gut. Das finde ich auf jeden Fall gut. Zum einen bekomme ich sehr viele, was heißt sehr viele, ist auch nicht richtig. Also mein Leben ist davon nicht unbedingt betroffen, nicht direkt. Aber du bekommst schon ab und zu mal irgendwelche Kommentare von Leuten, die ich sage mal zu großen Fans des jüdischen Volks sind, ohne zu anzuerkennen, dass es da massive Probleme gibt. Klassisches Beispiel, dieser Stereotyp, Juden sind reich, Juden sind schlau. Ich komme aus einer armen Familie. Große Teile meiner Großfamilie, also Tanten, Onkel und so, haben nicht mal die Schule abgeschlossen wegen Diskriminierung des Staates Israels, aber das ist ein ganz anderes Thema. Und eine Situation, die wirklich bei mir in Erinnerung für immer bleiben wird, es ist mir sehr, sehr wichtig hier in Köln, ich sage mal, freiwillige Arbeit mit Geflüchteten zu leisten, also seit meinem ersten Tag in Köln habe ich das angefangen und ich bin mit einigen Leuten aus Syrien, aus dem Irak befreundet und so. Vor ein paar Jahren gab es ja eine Situation, wo einer von denen zu mir kam und hat gesagt, Felix, ich brauche deine Hilfe. Ja, sag mal, worum geht es? Und der sagt mir, ich habe ein Problem mit meinem Visum und ich brauche einen Anwalt. Ich sage, woher soll ich einen Anwalt kennen? Ich bin genau so lange wie du in diesem Land. Der hat gesagt, nee, aber mir wurde erzählt, Juden sind alle schlau und deswegen sind sie gute Anwälte. Und ich sage, hör mal zu, mein Lieber, du sprichst gerade mit jemandem, der seinen ganzen Gehalt ausgibt, um den ersten Effizienkönig verlieren zu sehen. Wie schlau kann so jemand sein? Genau, das klingt mir nicht unbedingt logisch und schlau, deswegen würde ich davon abraten, dieses Stereotyp zu haben, die jüdischen Leute, wie alle Menschen auf dieser Erde, haben bessere Seiten, haben schlechtere Seiten. Es gibt schlechte Juden, es gibt gute Juden, es gibt schlaue, dumme, sehr viele arme Menschen innerhalb der jüdischen Welt. In Israel ist Armut auf jeden Fall ein krasses Thema, auch abgesehen von der heutigen Situation. Deswegen halte ich das für sehr wichtig, auch darüber zu sprechen, dass die jüdische Welt nicht nur in Sachen Herkunft und religiöser Praxis sehr divers ist, sondern auch in Sachen, was für Menschen da unterwegs sind. Ich sag mal so, ich bekomme immer so ein bisschen ein komisches Gefühl, wenn man mir gegenüber zu viel Liebe zeigt, weil ich jüdisch oder israeli bin. Ich bin ein Mensch wie alle anderen. Ich habe Interessen, die in die gleiche Richtung gehen, wie, würde ich sagen, die meisten der Menschen in meinem Alter in Deutschland. Deswegen muss man diesen Mittelweg finden zwischen empathisch zu fragen, darüber zu sprechen, dass es da kulturelle Unterschiede gibt, Unterschiede was die Herkunft betrifft und so weiter, aber einem nicht das Gefühl zu geben, dass man anders ist. Und das ist die Kunst, die man in Deutschland nicht so gut beherrscht, leider, muss man sagen. Und da bin ich mir sicher, es geht nicht nur um Jüdinnen und Juden, sondern um viele Leute mit migrantischer Hintergrund, mit anderen Religionen, mit anderem Aussehen. An die Zöhren und Zöhren, wenn ich sage andere, mache ich so in Anführungsstrichen mit den Händen, damit es klar wird, das sind keine anderen Menschen, das sind Menschen wie alle anderen. Und das möchte ich so klar wie möglich machen und ich hoffe, dass dieser Botschaft tatsächlich auch ankommt. Ich sage mal so.
Naja, es ist halt insofern auch nochmal doppelt relevant, weil wir eben nicht nur einen Konflikt haben, der in seine Wurzel aus den Religionen kommt, sondern weil es ja eigentlich auch total paradox ist, wann werde ich mal in meinem Leben als Christ adressiert? Also eigentlich nur, wenn Markus Söder vermeintlich glaubt, von mir eine Stimme bekommen zu haben, dann sagt er zu mir, wir sind doch alle Christen. Aber die Juden werden, mache ich ja auch jetzt gerade, du wirst quasi über eine Religion wird Identifikation geschaffen. Und in Teilen haben wir das jetzt mit Musliminnen und Muslimen, haben wir das in Deutschland gerade auch. Und das ist ja, also ich glaube, viele unserer Generationen, natürlich nicht alle, man kann nie für alle sprechen, aber würden sich dem ganz krass verwehren. Als Christ vereinnahmt zu werden und für irgendetwas verantwortlich gemacht zu werden, was sogar die katholische Kirche gemacht hat, selbst mit der evangelischen habe ich große Probleme mit vielen Dingen, die sie tun. Aber bei den Juden und Jüdinnen ist eben genau das das Gefäß, in das man gesteckt wird. Und das eben vor dem Hintergrund und ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist jetzt eine Frage an dich, dass vielleicht auch daher dein Wunsch kommt, viel zu wissen über deine Religion. Ich nehme das Recht heraus, ganz viel schon wieder vergessen zu haben, was ich mal gelernt habe über das Christentum. Aber vielleicht möchtest du deswegen auch dich so gut auskennen, weil du dann eben aus einer Position des Wissens heraus gegenargumentieren kannst, was ja paradox ist, wenn du dich vielleicht im ersten Moment gar nicht so sehr für diese Religion interessiert hättest. Aber weil sie immer dir zugeschrieben wird und du ihr quasi eingeschrieben wirst, musst du dir über Wissen dann die Möglichkeit geben, dich da raus zu argumentieren.
Ich finde es eine sehr interessante Analyse. Ich muss sagen, dass ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass diese Analyse für viele Judeninnen und Juden richtig ist, die in Deutschland geboren sind oder groß geworden sind. Für mich persönlich, als jemand, der in Israel sozialisiert worden ist, ist das, muss ich sagen, weniger relevant, aus der Tatsache, dass –also es ist schon ein Fakt, dass ich in einer religiösen Familie groß geworden bin. Das wurde mir ja nicht –also das ist kein Stereotyp, sondern das ist richtig. Ich finde es aber auch wichtig, anzumerken, dass die jüdische Gemeinde in Deutschland und viele jüdische Juden hier gar nicht religiös sind, also das Judenzum ist auch so ein ethnischer Gruppe. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass die Religion the be all and all ist, sondern es geht um Kultur, es geht um Geschichte, es geht um Sachen, die eigentlich vielleicht von der Religion geprägt sind, aber mit der Religion nicht direkt zu tun haben. Ich kann nur über meine Generation und Jünger sprechen, von den Leuten, die ich kenne, ist natürlich keine repräsentative Umfrage, aber andererseits muss man ganz klar sagen, die Menschen, die ich kenne aus der jüdischen Bubble sind in der Regel sehr cool, die sind in der Regel kulturell interessiert, die haben sehr coole Hobbys, die leben ihr Leben fast genauso wie viele andere Menschen in dem Alter in Deutschland. Und es ist auch so, dass sie jüdisch sind, also dass die Familie jüdisch ist aus unterschiedlichen Ecken und Gründen und Herkunft und so weiter und das muss auch gesagt werden. Also ich sag mal so, du würdest mich auf der Straße sehen, würdest du nicht direkt sagen, naja, der ist Jude. Also das muss man auch sagen.
Wann denkt man darüber überhaupt nach?
Das ist auch eine gute Frage. Ja, genau. Also und das muss gesagt werden, dass diese Elemente müssen auch ankommen, dass es die Juden, nochmal in Anführungsstrichen, nicht gibt. Das gibt es nicht. Das ist ein Konstrukt, was man in den Kopf steckt, um alles leichter zu machen oder alles leichter machen zu können. Aber diese Bubble, die jüdische Bubble in Deutschland, auch im Allgemeinen, ist super kompliziert. Es gibt unfassbar viele Streitereien, unfassbar viele unterschiedliche Positionen, unterschiedliche Arten vom Leben und dass man diesen Begriff verwendet in der, ich sag mal in der Debatte, die Juden sind XY, das ist genauso falsch und verallgemeinert, wie zu sagen, was weiß ich, ja, wie du schon sagtest, die Muslimen, es gibt, was weiß ich, wie viele Billarden von Muslimen auf der Erde, das sind keine Gruppe, wo alle gleich sind und das ist genauso mit uns, nur, dass wir als Gruppe viel kleiner sind, das ist halt der Unterschied. Aber sonst ist das wirklich sehr vielfältig und selbst die offiziellen Organisationen, die für die jüdische Gemeinde verantwortlich sind, selbst die vertreten diese ganze Vielfalt nicht. Es ist viel, viel größer als das und das muss gesagt werden, finde ich.
Ja, deswegen fand ich das jetzt sehr interessant, damit auch einzusteigen und gleichzeitig, du hast es schon so ein bisschen erwähnt, finde ich aber auch deinen Bezug zum Fußball eben besonders interessant. Also du hast es in anderen Podcasts auch schon ausführlicher erzählt, das muss man jetzt nicht nochmal in derselben Ausführlichkeit nacherzählen. Ich werde das alles verlinken, also unter anderem bei der lieben Mara hast du in Flutlicht an da sehr viel drüber geredet. Du bist vor acht Jahren, ist es jetzt glaube ich, dann nach Deutschland gekommen, nach Köln und der Fußball war letztlich der Integrator für dich in die Stadtgemeinschaft, in, ich weiß nicht, ob Gesellschaft jetzt ein zu großes Wort ist, das kannst du besser beurteilen, aber unter anderem weil du darüber auch die Sprache gelernt hast. Kannst du kurz dazu was erzählen, was dein Video zum Fußball hier in Deutschland gekommen ist?
Gerne, also ich bin tatsächlich angekommen und ich konnte die Sprache nicht. Ich kannte, alles was ich wusste über dieses Land war tatsächlich alles, was man halt im Ausland weiß, was weiß ich, Angela Merkel, Bayern, München, Zweiter Weltkrieg, ungefähr.
Der Reihenfolge und...
Genau, Rammstein. Also das ist... Ja, genau, so schlimm war das und dann kommt man hierhin an und denkt man sich, wie komme ich hier zurecht? Wie erfahrt... Also ich bin ein sehr politischer Mensch, ich war seit immer ein sehr politischer Mensch und ich wollte tatsächlich herausfinden, was in dieser Gesellschaft so bewegend ist, was für Themen wichtig sind, was bedeutet rechts und links hier, was bedeutet hier... Ja, was sind die radikalen Seiten der beiden politischen Seiten und da war der Fußball sehr hilfreich für mich. Das war die Sprache, die ich... ich konnte die Sprache Fußball sprechen, obwohl ich die Sprache Deutsch nicht sprechen konnte. Und deswegen, die Sprache der Fan-Kultur und wie man sich verhält in einer Kurve, das war mir früher bekannt. Also es ist nicht so, dass ich zum ersten Mal zu Fußball gegangen bin in Deutschland. Und deswegen waren diese Voraussetzungen da, um mir zu helfen und um mir sehr viel Info zu geben. Ich wusste auch, dass es überall auf der Welt so ist, also in vielen Ländern und vielen Städten, so ist, dass manche Ultra-Gruppen sich auch politisch äußern. Da dachte ich mir, ich gehe halt sehr viele Fußballspiele zu sehen und mal schauen, was ich herausfinde. Und am Anfang war es einfach beim Hoppen. Also ich gucke, ich bin irgendwo und ich gucke mir, wo es ein Spiel gibt. Ich gehe hin und merke, was ich sehe und was ich verstehe. Ich höre so einen Gesang, ich versuche zu verstehen, was man sieht. So Google ein bisschen, Google Translate und so weiter. Dann, ein paar Jahre danach, habe ich tatsächlich angefangen, regelmäßig mit dem FC auswärts zu fahren und Mitglied im Verein zu werden und so weiter. Und jeder solche Schritt war für mich noch ein Schritt weiter, um diese Gesellschaft im Allgemeinen und auch die Gesellschaft in den unterschiedlichen Regionen in diesem Land besser zu verstehen. Ich sage mal so, wenn du von Köln aus nach Stuttgart fährst, wirst du ein bisschen eine andere Art von Sprache hören. Das ist halt so. Und das sind alles Sachen, die ich tatsächlich tue. Der Fußball war für mich ein Mittel, um das alles zu erfahren, um vor Ort zu sein, um Sachen zu sehen und zu hören und mit Menschen zu sprechen, die die Sprache Fußball und die Sprache Fan-Kultur sehr gut beherrschen. Und das hat mich sehr geholfen und es hilft mir immer noch. Ich meine, es ist nicht so, dass ich heutzutage der Meinung bin, ich weiß alles. Es gibt sehr viel zu sehen, sehr viel zu erfahren. Und jedes Mal, dass ich was Neues lerne und das passiert mir, das glauben mir fast jeden Tag, ist das für mich eine sehr große Freude. Und das hilft mir, sowohl meine Arbeit besser zu machen, als auch einfach ein besser informierter Mensch zu sein. Weil im Endeffekt, im Endeffekt lebe ich hier. Ich bleibe hier. Ich möchte Teil dieses Systems, Teil der politischen Landschaft hier zu sein. Man möchte wählen, man möchte irgendwie politisch involviert zu sein. Das sind alles Wünsche, die mir wichtig sind. Und mit der Hilfe des Fußballs kann ich das viel besser machen und ich kann viel besser beurteilen, in welcher Ecke ich hingehöre. Und im Übrigen ist das auch sehr einfach und viel einfacher für mich, durch die aktiven Akteure in dem Fußball auch zu erfahren, was die problematischen Seiten dieser Ecke sind, wo ich hingehöre. Das ist auch wichtig zu wissen. Ich meine, das ist nicht so, dass alles perfekt ist und alle Menschen haben genau ihre Ecke, die für sie da sind, sondern im politischen Aktivismus gibt es Ecken, die manchmal, wo Meinungen unterwegs sind, wo ich nicht unterschreiben würde. Für mich war der Fußball der Zugang und vor allem die Fan-Kultur, glaube ich, mehr als der Fußball an sich. Aber der Fußball macht auch manchmal Spaß und das hilft auf jeden Fall. Diese Emotionalität, die mit dem Spiel kommt, die führt Menschen zu besserem Verständnis voneinander, wenn man diese Emotionen tatsächlich nicht nur versteht im Kopf, sondern fühlt im Herzen. Das war zum Glück so bei mir. Und wie gesagt, mit jedem Gespräch wäre das nur noch interessanter für mich. Sowohl beruflich als auch persönlich übrigens, das ist sehr wichtig zu sagen.
Also du berichtest jetzt eben sportjournalistisch, berichtest viel über Fan-Kultur, bist sehr aktiv in sozialen Netzwerken und bei Medien. Alles hat angefangen bei der Deutschen Welle. Aber weil du das jetzt nochmal so betont hast, dass die Gespräche dabei so wichtig waren, und da geht es ja jetzt nicht mehr nur um das Lernen der Sprache, sondern eben auch um das Verstehen dieser Welt, dieser Gesellschaft, in der man lebt. Welcher ist denn da der wichtigere Ort für dich? Ist es tatsächlich das Stadion oder sind es nicht vielleicht eher die Reisen zum Stadion und vom Stadion weg, wo solche Gespräche stattfinden?
Alles zusammen, würde ich sagen. Also einerseits ist das eine berechtigte Frage. Der Weg hin zum Stadion. Auf dem Weg hörst du Sachen, bekommst du irgendwelche Wortwahlen mit. Du merkst, was Menschen singen, du merkst, was Gruppendynamik mit Menschen macht. Und du merkst auch, was Menschen in ihrem, also das betrifft vor allem Männer in bestimmten Altern, muss man sagen, aber in ihrem Safe Space, noch mal in Anführungsstrichen, machen, wie sie sich verhalten. Und wie gesagt, was für Gesänge gesungen werden, was für Motiven gibt es auf T-Shirts und auf Jacken und auf Kuten und auf was weiß ich. Ich finde tatsächlich das Thema Kuten ein Thema, das ist tatsächlich eine anthropologische Reise für mich. Jedes Mal, dass ich jemanden mit einer Kute sehe, denke ich mir, ja, also jeden kleinen Patch ist tatsächlich, erzählt eine Geschichte für mich, als jemand, der in diesem Land nicht sozialisiert worden ist. Also oft genug ist diese Geschichte auch nicht cool, muss man sagen. Also der Fußball in Deutschland ist heutzutage nicht perfekt, aber es war noch weniger perfekt in der Vergangenheit der 70er, 80er Jahre und was für politische Meinungen in den Rängen vertreten waren. Aber wie gesagt, das habe ich nicht selbst erlebt. Und deswegen muss ich das von irgendwoher erfahren. Und Kuten und Aufkleber und alte Banner sind für mich so und so das Mittel. Und dann kommen wir zum Stadion. Und im Stadion gibt es einige Fan-Gruppierungen und auch einige Vereine, aber mich interessieren vor allem die Fan-Gruppierungen und Ultra-Gruppierungen, die diese Bühne auch auf eine Art und Weise benutzen, um ihre Botschaften zu vermitteln. Und das finde ich wirklich jedes Mal interessant. Manchmal geht es tatsächlich um politischen Aktivismus. Es geht um Botschafter, die mit Zuständen in der Gesellschaft oder auf der Welt zu tun haben, mit Dingen, die manchmal auch mit dem Fan-Dasein zu tun haben, was auch wichtig ist. Fanrechte, Anstoßzeiten, Ticketpreise und. Das sind Sachen, die auch wichtig sind und dass man diese Bühne benutzt, um diese Botschafter in die Welt zu tragen, halte ich auch für sehr, sehr wichtig. Man könnte argumentieren, dass es tatsächlich, ich sage mal, am spannendsten ist, wenn es tatsächlich in Richtung politischer Botschafter geht. Aber für mich persönlich, ich sage mal so, politische Botschafter halte ich für sehr, sehr wichtig. Der Fußball ist und bleibt politisch und so ist die Fan-Kultur. Es ist aber auch wichtig, darüber zu sprechen, dass viele Menschen auf den Regen auch von diesen Elementen betroffen sind. Das heißt nicht, dass, ich sage mal, Ticketpreise in Deutschland genauso wie strukturelle Diskriminierung sind. Auf gar keinen Fall. Es sind aber Themen, die Menschen beschäftigen. Und ich kann nur über mein Beispiel sprechen. Natürlich, wenn man über Diskriminierung oder sich gegen Antisemitismus stellt und nicht das im Stadion mitbekommt. Natürlich freut es mich. Es freut mich aber auch, wie gesagt, auf total persönlicher Wahrnehmung, freut es mich aber auch zu sehen, dass es Menschen, die für Fanrechte sich einsetzen und sagen, ja, Fans und Fußballfans sind Akteurinnen in dieser Gesellschaft und sie haben Rechte und über diese Rechte müssen wir sprechen, sei es in Sachen Polizeiehwahl, sei es in Sachen, wie gesagt, Ticketpreis-Anstoßzeiten und und und. Und mich persönlich ist das, also ich sag mal so, in meinem Alltag oder es kommt sehr häufiger, es kommt viel häufiger vor, dass meine Rechte als Fußballfan verletzt werden in dieser Gesellschaft. Manchmal häufiger sogar als, was weiß ich, antisemitische Aussagen, also es ist mir sehr wenige Male passiert in diesem Land, muss man fairerweise, es ist passiert. Einmal ist zu viel schon, aber man muss fairerweise sagen, der Antisemitismus heutzutage ist viel komplexer als du scheiß Jude. Und man muss sich auskennen, um das zu erkennen. Und obwohl es auch das leider immer noch gibt.
Genau, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich da sagen würde, man muss fairerweise sagen.
Also das ist die Wortwahl eines Ausländers. Aber es sind tatsächlich alles Themen, die wichtig sind auf unterschiedlichen Graden. Und obwohl das unterschiedliche Graden sind, heißt nicht, dass andere Sachen, dass man darüber spricht, ist nicht wichtig. Ich halte es auf jeden Fall für sehr wichtig, diese Bühne zu benutzen. Und deswegen halte ich das für äußerst wichtig, dass Fan-Gruppierungen hier sowohl im Bereich politischer Botschafter, als auch in anderen Bereichen, die auch dem Fan betreffen, sich äußern. Und das ist für mich jedes Mal spannend.
Ja, ich finde das halt insofern eine interessante Frage, weil man ja, man hat ja zwei verschiedene soziale Orte. Also die Anreise zum Stadion, egal wie die jetzt stattfindet, da sind wir noch Individuen und in dem Moment, in dem wir im Stadion sind, da löst sich das Individuum in der Masse auf, egal wie man das jetzt bezeichnen möchte. Und auch deshalb, so argumentieren zumindest oft Soziologen, ist das Stadion ein Ort der Enthämmung, in der dann eben auch in der Masse, man sich Dinge erlaubt, die man sich persönlich nie erlauben würde. Und die interessante Frage ist ja dann, gerade wenn wir dann über Diskriminierendes Verhalten sprechen. Also du hast jetzt viele Positiv-Beispiele gebracht, mit Transparenten, mit Aktionen von Fans. Das ist ja aber oft eine strukturierte und vorbereitete Kommunikation. Aber die spontane Kommunikation, die ist ja diejenige, in der oft die Grenzen überschritten werden, in der Sexismus stattfindet, Rassismus, Antisemitismus und so weiter. Und darüber werden wir ja auch heute sprechen. Und die Frage, die man dann stellen kann, was von beiden zeigt den wahren Menschen, ist der Mensch als wahr dann anzusehen, wenn er enthemmt ist und quasi glaubt, sich alles erlauben zu können? Oder ist er es in dem geschützten Raum vorher und nachher, wo zumindest, also es ist natürlich auch nicht immer so, ich bin auch schon mit U-Bahn mitgefahren, wo also da waren nicht mehr viele Individuen, sondern sehr viel dumme Masse zu sehen. Aber du verstehst, glaube ich, meinen Punkt. Und da hätten mich eben deine Gedanken zu interessiert. Wo glaubst du, kann man tiefer in die Seele der Menschen blicken? Oder hast du da vielleicht auch wegen deiner Erfahrungen, du hast als Ordner gearbeitet in Israel und du hast in vielen Podcasts und Texten ja auch schon erklärt, dass dort allein die Sprache, die verwendet wird, das ist ultra hart. Also wenn es irgendwelche Fangesänge gibt mit Zyklon B, wenn andere Gegner als Deutsche bezeichnet werden, als Schimpfwort natürlich gedacht. Man hat es mehrfach in verschiedenen Podcasts, wo du warst, auch gehört, dass da die Gastgeber schwer schlucken mussten, weil das eben so undenkbar eigentlich fast ist. Aber wie denkst du darüber? Wo sehen wir quasi, wie die Menschen wirklich sind? In der Masse oder wenn man dann doch im Einzelnen mit ihnen spricht?
Es gibt im Juden-Show mein Prinzip, dass die Säle des Menschen aus, by default, schlecht ist, es sei denn, es wurde anders bewiesen. Das glaube ich persönlich nicht. Ich glaube schon, dass die beiden Seiten, die du gerade geschildert hast, auf jeden Fall da sind. Ich finde es auf jeden Fall wichtig, das zu sehen. Ich halte es für äußerst wichtig, dass beide Seiten genauso viel darüber gesprochen werden, wie er sowohl über die Seite, die schwieriges Verhalten und übergriffiges Verhalten in Verbindung mit dem Fußball ausübt. Da muss man sagen, das Thema Sexismus ist tatsächlich da weit, weit, weit voran. Keine Frage. Das sind aber auch Menschen, die diese Transpies in manchen Stadien hochhalten und versuchen, was dagegen zu tun. Menschen sind unterschiedlich und ich könnte wirklich jeden und jeder verstehen, zum Beispiel, die man sagt, das ist mir zu viel. Also diesen Unterschied machen zu können, das ist auch irgendwie, wofür man ein bisschen Hintergrundwissen haben muss. Und das haben einige Menschen auch nicht und ist verständlich. Also ich würde nicht erwarten, wenn jemand kein Interesse an Fußball hat, dass man sich mit Fan-Gruppierungen auseinandersetzen würde. Und mit Vereinen und Fans ist das ein bisschen nicht realistisch. Und deswegen würde ich schon dafür appellieren, auch die kritischen Seiten zu thematisieren und darüber zu sprechen, was man dagegen tun kann, weil das auch Teil des Ganzen ist. Und so ist das zu bewerten, finde ich. Also Fußball ist für mich eine sehr komplexe Welt, wo es keinen Satz gibt, den ich mehr hasse als Fußball ist Spiegelbildergesellschaft. Ich finde schon, dass Fußball einige Extremen aus der Gesellschaft vertritt. Einerseits tatsächlich, was für Aktivismus es geben könnte und was diese Strukturen für Gutes auf der Welt bewirken können. Andererseits muss man fairerweise sagen, dass es auch Elemente im Fußball gibt, die auch übergriffiges Verhalten ausüben und fühlen sich damit total okay. Das sind zwei komplexe Seiten und über beide müssen wir sprechen, finde ich. Denn es gibt keine Fußballwelt, die man für sich selbst ausmalen kann und sagt, hier ist alles cool, hier sprechen wir nur über Menschenrechte und was wir machen können und so weiter. Das sind alles Teile dieser Welt. Es ist eine komplexe Welt, es ist eine sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Welt, mit unterschiedlichen Ecken, mit unterschiedlichen Menschen. Aber diese Arbeit, diese Auseinandersetzung muss man tun, erst recht als Journalisten. Aber eigentlich finde ich das wichtig für jeden Fußballfan, der oder die damit konfrontiert ist jedes Wochenende. Und da komme ich zum Schlusswort. Genau das halte ich so problematisch. Menschen, die sagen, na ja, politische Botschafter im Stadion, ich komme ins Stadion, ich sehe ein Spiel, ich gehe nach Hause. Was hat das mit Politik zu tun? Na ja, für diese Menschen, die das sagen, könnte es sein, dass es nichts mit Politik zu tun haben, weil die die die die schlechtere Seite nicht erleben. Wenn man als weißer großer Mann ins Stadion geht, natürlich wird man nicht kein, also eher tendenziell weniger übergriffiges Verhalten erleben als eine Frau, die ins Stadion alleine geht. Das muss man sagen. Das muss man klar so klar benennen wie möglich. Noch ein Beispiel, ich habe so eine Aktion gepostet auf Instagram, wo es darum ging, dass ein Zusammengeschluss von FC-Fans aus meiner Szene Geld sammeln durch Schallverkäufe für die israelische Selbstsorge-Organisation. Und da kamen sehr viele sehr viele Kommentare, naja, Politik raus aus dem Stadion. Und das ist genau das Ding. Es ist für die keine politische Frage, ob man in den Stadion geht oder nicht. Man kann es halt machen. Für mich oder für viele unische Menschen, und es geht nicht nur für Fußball, sondern auch für andere Bereiche in dieser Gesellschaft, muss man sich Gedanken machen, gehe ich in diese Ecke, was für Anmerkungen werde ich hören, was für Gesänge werde ich hören. Sobald man sich Gedanken macht, was für Erlebnisse ich jetzt machen werde und ob ich davor vorsichtig sein muss, dann fängt die Politik an. Das machen sich viele, viele Menschen in Bezug auf Fußball, und das muss man anerkennen. Und genau darum geht es, finde ich. Zum Glück gibt es in Deutschland auch genug Orgas und Fan-Gruppierungen, die sich damit auseinandersetzen. Es könnte viel mehr werden. Ich finde dieses Thema wirklich sehr wichtig. Aber man merkt, dass der Anfang da ist und dass es schon was Gutes ist.
Ja, und das Privileg, sich mit Themen nicht auseinandersetzen zu müssen, das hast du ja schon richtig identifiziert. Und ich glaube, wir werden auf beide Punkte, also sowohl wie funktioniert das Stadion als sozialer Ort und eben auch Politik im Stadion und Check Your Privileges, was er erlaubt ist. Da werden wir sicherlich im Verlauf dieser Sendung noch zukommen. Ich kann nur empfehlen, du hast auch ganz viel interessante Dinge über Fußball in Israel erzählt zum Beispiel. Also da kann ich, es gibt eine tolle Folge vom Karl-Andreser-Podcast. Blutlicht an habe ich schon empfohlen. Ich fand auch die Sendung bei Brennpunkt Orange, da wird es auch manche Überschneidung hiermit geben. Ich versuche, dass es nicht zu viel ist. All das ist in den Show notes verlinkt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da könnt ihr noch weiterhören. Jetzt lasst uns dann aber mal zum traurigen Anlass dieser Sendung kommen. Zum 7. Oktober und dem Anschlag der Hamas auf Jüdinnen und Juden. Unglaublich viele ermordete, verschleppte Menschen, Gräueltaten, wie man sie nicht für möglich gehalten hätte, was aber auch schon eine sehr privilegierte Aussage ist. Es ist dennoch so. Wie hast du diesen Tag erlebt? Du musstest jetzt nicht zu privat halten, erzähl was du möchtest. Und wie hat sich das dann ausgewirkt? Erst mal auf den Sport und auf den Fußball in Israel. Und dann können wir in zweiten und dritten Schritt dann auch noch in andere Länder gucken.
Also danke für diese Frage. Ich glaube schon, dass es wichtig ist, tatsächlich so persönlich wie möglich, um zu verstehen, wie krass dieser Tag war. Man muss erst mal ganz klar sagen, ich werde versuchen, das ohne irgendwelche getriggerte Inhalte zu erzählen. Es ist aber ein sehr emotionales Thema für mich. Deswegen sage ich Ihnen vorab Triggerwarnung, Tod, Terror, Mord, und möglicherweise auch sexualisierte Gewalt, bevor ich anfange. Und jetzt zum Inhaltlichen. An diesem Tag war ich im Bett in meiner Wohnung in Köln. Ich wache auf und sehe, dass es auf meinem Handy unbeantwortete Anrufe gab von einer sehr guten Freundin von mir aus Berlin, die auch Israeli ist. Ich dachte, ihr ist irgendetwas passiert oder so und ich habe angerufen und die hat irgendwie total einiges panisch gesagt, hast du die Nachrichten gesehen? Ich bin gerade aufgestanden, was geht? Die hat gesagt, mach Fernseher jetzt an. Terroristen, Jüden, große, große, große Probleme oder so nach dem Motto. Ich mach dann Fernseher an und was ich gesehen habe, ich konnte mich für zehn Minuten nicht bewegen. Ich stand einfach vor dem Fernsehen für zehn Minuten. Ich war total frozen. Ich konnte mich einfach nicht bewegen aus Schock. Und es ist nicht so, dass man aus Israel einiges nicht erlebt hat. Also Kriegeraketen, ich bin selbst im Süden groß geworden, geboren. Das heißt, ich habe einiges erlebt in diesem Leben. Und trotzdem war es sehr, sehr viel. Nach diesen zehn Minuten von Schock dachte ich mir, ach Moment mal, du hast Menschen dort. Die erste, die in meine Gedanken gekommen ist, ist meine Schwester. Meine Schwester wohnt in Tivot. Das ist eine Stadt, die sehr nah am Gazastreifen ist. Problem ist aber, dass meine Schwester streng religiös ist und der 7. Oktober schabbat war. Das heißt, Handy aus. Ich habe versucht, innerhalb dieser Stunde anzurufen. Keine Antwort, keine Antwort, keine Antwort, keine Antwort. Und mit jedem Anruf werde ich noch panischer. Ich habe mit meinen anderen Geschwistern gesprochen, die nicht religiös sind. Vielleicht können wir irgendwie mit den Nachbarn sprechen. Was weiß ich? Wir müssen von ihr hören. Und wie gesagt, ich habe selbst posttraumatische Erfahrungen. Ich leide unter PTBS und die Gedanken sind schon am Laufen. Was ist mit meiner Schwester, mit ihren Kindern passiert, mit ihrem Mann? Das Glück und das Glück total, total, total Banane eigentlich. Aber das Glück, das wir hatten, war, dass es an dem Tag so viele Sirenen gab. Und eine dieser Raketen hat ihr Haus eingetroffen. Zum Glück ist es nicht passiert, aber als eine Rakete auf ihr Haus geschossen worden ist, hat sie sich gedacht, es ist irgendwas los. Und nachdem eine Rakete in ihr Haus eingetroffen ist, hat sie das Handy tatsächlich angemacht an einem Samstag. Soweit ich war, war das das erste Mal in ihrem Leben, dass sie das getan haben, dass sie das Shabbat nicht eingehalten hat. Und sie hat meine Anrufe gesehen, sie hat mich direkt angerufen und hat gesagt, was ist los, Felix? Ich habe gesagt, du, deine Kinder, dein Mann, Bunkerzimmer jetzt und ihr bleibt dort, bis ich euch was sage. Sie war total panisch, also was ist los? Ich habe gesagt, es gibt Terroristen gerade überall in der Region. Es sind nicht nur Raketen, sondern da sind Menschen, die Menschen erschießen auf offener Straße. Ihr geht gerade direkt ins Bunkerzimmer und ihr bleibt dort. Und es war tatsächlich so, ihr ist zum Glück nicht passiert. Ihr Mann war auf dem Weg in die Synagoge. Als ich angerufen hatte, zum Glück konnte es so sein, dass Menschen auch ihm vorgewarnt haben und er ist direkt zurück nach Hause gegangen. Die mussten im Bunkerzimmer ca. 20 Stunden warten, bis sie das Bunkerzimmer verlassen konnten. Und dann sind sie direkt in Richtung Asturden, meine Heimatstadt, gefahren. Und denen ist zumindest körperlich nichts passiert. Aber nachdem ich gehört habe, denen geht es körperlich okay. Die Kinder sind total traumatisiert, aber andere Geschichte. Sie sind am Leben. Und dann denkt man sich, Moment mal, ich habe in dieser Region studiert. Ich habe da meinen Journalismus-Bastlös gemacht in der Stadt De Roth. Wirklich in so unmittelbar Nähe am Gaza-Streifen, dass ich vom Fenster Gaza sehen konnte, als ich das studiert habe. Und dann denkt man sich, man kennt einige Menschen, die da geblieben sind nach dem Studium, was ist mit denen passiert. Und das war ganz, ganz schrecklich, die Zahlen zu sehen, die die ganze Zeit hochsteigen und hochsteigen und hochsteigen. Am Anfang waren das 100 Menschen, die ermordet worden sind. Dann 200, dann 300, wirklich jede Stunde gehen, noch 100 Menschen kommen hinzu. Und das war ein wirklich krasser Tag. Und dann kamen die Geschichten von den Menschen, die das überlebt haben. Und das hat es wirklich viel schlimmer gemacht. Im Endeffekt waren das laut israelischen Angaben 1.210 Menschen, die ermordet worden sind. Von denen gibt es immer noch Menschen, die noch nicht identifiziert worden sind. Also es gibt Leichen, die bis jetzt nicht identifiziert worden sind, aus der Tatsache, dass die in so einem schlechten Zustand sind, wegen dem, was denen gemacht worden ist von den Terroristen. Und wir reden nicht nur über Mord, wir reden über total herabwürdiges Verhalten gegenüber Menschen. Wir reden über Vergewaltigungen. Und die Beschreibungen dieser Vergewaltigungen werden mich persönlich nie verlassen. Es ist krass. Natürlich ist jede Vergewaltigung und jede sexualisierte Gewalt schlimm. Das war irgendwie systematisch auf so einem Niveau, wo ich mir sagte, ich kann das nicht lesen. Das ist mir persönlich zu viel. Und ich könnte mir nicht mal ansatzweise vorstellen, was das mit Überlebten von sexualisierter Gewalt macht, sowas zu lesen. Und wie gesagt, dann kamen Namen hinzu von Menschen, die ich auch kannte. Es waren keine Enge-Freundinnen von mir, aber trotzdem Menschen, die man gesehen hat, mit denen man gesprochen hat. Es ist auf jeden Fall sehr krass und man redet darüber in sehr vielen Kreisen in Israel, als ob es vergleichbar mit dem Holocaust ist. Das ist faktisch betrachtet das größte Massaker an jüdischen Juden seit dem Holocaust, obwohl es erwähnt werden muss, dass auch nicht jüdische Juden ermordet worden sind, Beduinen, Palästinenserinnen mit israelischen Pass. Also das sind alles auch Leute, die aus dem Ausland kommen und in Israel waren zum Arbeiten, thailändische Menschen und und und. Also die Liste ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr lang. Aber die Idee war, dass dieser Tat gegen jüdische Juden gemacht wird. Und deswegen ist das eine klar antisemitische Terrortat. Und ich glaube, davon werden wir und werde ich persönlich nicht so schnell auf die Beine kommen. Das beschäftigt mich jeden Tag und das beschäftigt meine Menschen in Israel jeden Tag und auch hier. Es hat Einflüsse auch auf das Leben von Jüdinnen, Juden, auch von Israelis hier in Deutschland. Der Anstieg von antisemitischen Straftaten, das ist Realität und nicht nur in Sachen Statistik, sondern es gibt sehr viel, worüber man einfach nicht was man nicht anzeigt oder so. Ich kenne Menschen, die seit Wochen ihre Wohnung nicht verlassen haben, weil die Angst haben. Ich habe selbst meine Wohnung in der ersten Woche nach dem Kriegsausbruch nicht verlassen, weil ich mir dachte, wenn jemand gerade so eine Anmerkung macht in der Bahn, so nach dem Motto, was weiß ich, irgendwas zum Thema Hamas oder so, werde ich mich einfach nicht zurückhalten können, dass wir sich schlimm entwickeln. Und wie gesagt, ich spreche aus dem Privileg heraus eines Mannes, eines großen Mannes und aus dem Privileg heraus von jemandem, der nicht als jüdisch gelesen wird. Ich meine, ich sitze in der Bahn, ich sehe aus wie der letzte Hipster aus dem belgischen Viertel in Köln oder wie der letzte Casual aus der Südkurve in Köln. Und trotzdem hat es mich beschäftigt. Deswegen kann ich nicht mal ansatzweise vorstellen, was das macht mit Menschen, die auch nach außen jüdisch in Anführungsstrichen aussehen, die solche Symbole tragen. Das ist tatsächlich eine ganz schlimme Zeit und Menschen sind traumatisiert, sowohl in Israel als auch im Ausland. Und was die Zukunft da bringt, habe ich wirklich keine Ahnung. Also ich habe nicht mal eine Vermutung, wie es weitergeht, weder in Israel noch hier. Ich bin einfach baff und habe keine Ahnung, was für eine Zukunft man haben könnte, nachdem so was passiert ist in meiner Lebenszeit.
Ja, also ich nehme ganz viel daraus mit, aber zwei Punkte, die ich nochmal versuchen würde zu adressieren. Das eine ist, es war ein Tag der Entmenschlichung. Es ging darum, Menschen auf möglichst qualvolle Art und Weise zu töten. Das war ein Angriff und aus Hass kommt Hass, wenn sogar du, also jetzt natürlich in großen Anführungszeichen, aber du bist hier in Deutschland, du warst nicht betroffen, du hast irre Ängste, auch du hast Menschen verloren. Also ich will das nicht kleinreden. Aber selbst wenn du, der über die Taten nur lesen musst und der versuchen konnte, Bildern aus dem Weg zu gehen, so wie viele von uns wahrscheinlich versucht haben, Bildern aus dem Weg zu gehen, wenn sogar du das Gefühl hast, ich kann jetzt nicht mich in eine beliebige Bahn setzen, weil sollte jemand das Wort Hamas erwähnen, dann weiß ich nicht, was aus mir herausbricht. Das zeigt ja schon, wie wirkmächtig das einfach ist. Also Hass erzeugt Hass. Und das ist auch allen Betroffenen nicht übelzunehmend zu verurteilen. Es geht sowieso nicht darum, was andere darüber denken. Aber das muss man sich bewusst sein, dass je tiefer die Menschen verstrickt sind in diesem Konflikt durch persönliche Beziehungen, desto tiefer ist dieses Gefühl. Und während es für mich eher ein Gefühl der Ohnmacht ist und der Hilflosigkeit, ist es dann für jemanden wie dich schon mehr ein Gefühl des Zornseins. Muss es natürlich nicht. Und das ist, glaube ich, ganz auf einer Ebene, die wir hier, wir privilegierten Deutschen, die vielleicht nur ganz indirekte Bezüge zu Menschen vor Ort haben, die wir auch manchmal vergessen. Manchmal auch in unseren Forderungen. Also man kann ja die wildesten Entwicklungen sehen. Politischer Lager, wie sie sich jetzt positionieren. Ich will jetzt an der Stelle noch gar nicht ins Detail gehen, weil darum geht es jetzt gerade an diesem Aspekt nicht. Aber da, ich glaube, das wird manchmal auch vergessen. Und das Zweite ist, und das scheint jetzt banal, aber nur, dass ich das richtig verstanden habe. Also Sirenenalarm und Raketenalarm ist in der Gegend, wo deine Schwester wohnt, so normal, dass erst, als die Rakete ihr Haus getroffen hat, sie dann ihr Handy angemacht hat und gedacht hat, okay, jetzt ist was anders als sonst.
Und ich kann noch was sagen in dem Zusammenhang von dem, was du gerade gesagt hast. Ich glaube, für mich ein bisschen Hintergrund dazu. Ich komme aus der linken Ecke der israelischen Politik. Ich sehe vieles, was in den letzten, nicht nur in den letzten Jahren, sondern generell strukturell in Israel schief läuft. Und ich kritisiere das auch sehr öffentlich, sowohl wenn ich in Israel bin als auch, wenn ich hier bin. Ich finde es sehr, sehr wichtig, das zu sagen. Menschenrechtsverletzungen sind Menschenrechtsverletzungen. Es ist keine Frage. Es ist egal, wer sie betreibt. Und das werde ich persönlich immer mein Bestes geben, um das zu benennen auch. Ich glaube, das war das erste Mal in meinem Leben, also diese ein paar Tage nach dem Angriff. Es ist mittlerweile zum Glück nicht mehr so. Wo ich einfach keinen Platz für das Leiden der anderen Seite hatte. Ich war so beschäftigt mit meinem eigenen Leid, mit meinen eigenen Ängsten, mit den Ängsten, dass Menschen, die ich kenne, tatsächlich ums Leben gekommen sind, was passiert ist. Mit den Sorgen, was gerade mit meiner Familie passiert, wo wir und meine Schwester wohnen, mit meinen Neffen. Also das sind Gedanken, die mich so krass beschäftigt haben, dass ich mir nicht mal Gedanken gemacht habe, was gerade mit den Zivilisten in Gaza passiert ist. Und das, wie gesagt, ich habe genug solche Situationen erfahren, wo es eine Art, auf Hebräisch heißt es eine Runde zwischen Israel und Hamas. Es heißt nicht Krieg, jetzt heißt es ein Krieg. Aber, ich sag mal so, 21 heißt offiziell eine Runde auf Hebräisch. 2014 heißt offiziell eine Runde zwischen Israel und Hamas. Und jedes Mal, genau, wie ein Boxkampf. Und jedes Mal, dass es diese Runde gab, war es mir von Anfang an sehr wichtig zu sagen, es gibt Sachen, die in meinem Namen geschehen sind, die ich nicht gut finde. Und die ich auch nach außen kritisiere. Die ersten Tage nach diesem Angriff, nach diesem schrecklichen, schrecklichen Samstag, war, glaube ich, das erste Mal in meinem Erwachsenenleben, wo ich mir sagte, ich habe gerade so krasse Existenzängste, dass ich überleben muss, erst mal, bevor ich über andere denke. Wie gesagt, zum Glück ist es nicht mehr so. Also ich spüre schon, dass es mich auch emotional interessiert, was in Gaza passiert. Wie gesagt, als linker Israel ist es mir sehr wichtig, nicht nur zu sagen, Hamas ist scheiße und das war's, sondern das Bild ist komplexer als das. Obwohl dieser Satz richtig ist, natürlich, und da gibt es keine Frage. Aber es gibt auch in Gaza unschuldige Menschen, die gerade sterben. Das muss man ansprechen. Und das Leid der Menschen muss man sehen. Ich glaube auch, wie gesagt, aus meiner israelischen Perspektive muss man auch darüber sprechen, wie der israelische Staat gerade Proteste gegen den Krieg versucht zu unterdrücken. Und auch mit Gewalt, mit Polizeigewalt und Repression, wie arabische Israelis gerade für wirklich kleinen Posts auf Social Media festgenommen werden. Das ist alles Teil des Systems. Und das alles sind Sachen, die man ansprechen muss, wenn man tatsächlich sich für Menschenrechte einsetzt und für die Rechte aller Menschen. Nicht nur, dass es uns nie wieder passiert, sondern dass es nie wieder passiert, Punkt. Und dieser Angriff hat das Leben vieler Linken, Israelis und Juden und Jüdinnen sehr, sehr schwer gemacht, vor allem aus der zivilistischen Ecke. Und ich bin da nicht anders. Aber wie gesagt, das sind trotzdem Themen, die für mich schon wichtig sind, anzusprechen. Und trotzdem, es gibt keine Berechtigung und es gibt keine Situation, die so eine krasse Art von Hass ausüben und so krasse Taten, so unmenschliche Taten ausüben. Das kann ich persönlich, also ich sag mal so, da gibt es einen Konflikt zwischen dem politischen Menschen in mir und dem jüdischen Menschen in mir. Den politischen Menschen in mir sagt immer, naja, alles hat Kontext, aber dieses Überleben, was ich habe als Jude auf dieser Welt, der ist gerade so stark unterwegs, dass ich mir meine, es ist egal, was für Kontext das ist. Und das ist auch richtig, finde ich. Man tut sowas nicht. Man hat vergewaltigt, Frauen nicht umzuschauen. Wir sind die besseren Menschen und wir werden siegen, sozusagen im politischen Sinne. Man bringt nicht hunderte von jungen Menschen, die auf einer Party waren, einfach so, weil man einen politischen Punkt setzen möchte. Das sind Hasstaten und gegen antisemitischen Hass muss man sich stellen. Und es ist egal, was man von dem Konflikt macht und was für eine Meinung man hat über den Ablauf dieses Konflikts. Und dieser Ablauf ist auf jeden Fall sehr kompliziert, definitiv. Und trotzdem ist es für mich so, jeder Person und jede Organisation, die nach dem 7. Oktober versucht haben, alles zu relativieren, sind für mich keine Partner mehr. Ich werde mit diesen Leuten nicht mehr sprechen. Es gibt einige Leute, mit denen ich gearbeitet habe, die ich getroffen habe im Fußballkontext, die ich nicht mehr treffen werde, mit denen möchte ich nicht mehr arbeiten, nicht mehr zu tun haben, weil es tatsächlich darum geht, Antisemitismus zu relativieren. Und das geht einfach nicht.
Ja, und das ist das, was Hass macht. Also Hass, selbst wir als, ich glaube, wir sind sonst Menschen, die nicht so viel hassen, außer vielleicht irgendwie, wenn ein Team ein Tor schießt, was wir nicht so mögen. Aber selbst da ist es so, dass man ja schon im Grunde seines Herzens weiß, das tut zwar gerade weh, aber es ist dann doch nur Fußball. Aber das ist das, was passiert und ich möchte an der Stelle einen O-Ton einspielen. Ich habe nur einen O-Ton mitgebracht, aber der ist mir so wichtig. Ich werde dazu auch noch kurz erklären, warum. Das war Yuval Noah Harari. Seine Bücher sind sowieso unbestreitbar toll. Der hat im Zeitgespräch etwas genau darüber gesagt, nämlich auf die Auswirkungen des 7. Oktober, auf die Menschen vor Ort und was er jetzt aber dann von den Menschen, die nicht vor Ort sind, fordert. Und das möchte ich einmal kurz einspielen und dann sage ich auch noch kurz was dazu. Die erste Antwort war ein Schock auf die Militärverbreitung. Wenn du für einen einzelnen Moment auf die Schmerzen von anderen Menschen zählen willst, dann kann ich dir sagen, dass ich mich nicht mehr in der Zeit der Schmerzen von anderen Menschen, wie die Palästinens Zivilisten in Gaza, in der ich mich total beträgt fühle. Ich denke auch, dass ich die Palästinens nicht für die Schmerzen der Israelis sympathisch haben kann. Denn sie sind auch komplett im Schmerz. Ich hoffe, das haben alle Hörerinnen und Hörer verstanden, obwohl es jetzt auf Englisch war, aber das wollte ich jetzt in dieser Länge auch nochmal hier einspielen, weil ich glaube, also dieser Anschlag und alles was auch danach gekommen ist und die Bodenoffensive im Gaza und auch viele Dinge über die wir jetzt dann gleich noch sprechen werden, wir sind immer nur nicht beim Fußball gelandet, aber so sei es nun eben. Das hat ganz viel mit Positionierung zu tun, das hat ganz viel mit Schmerz zu tun und die Unterscheidung, die Harari da macht, die ist ja so logisch wie aber auch glaube ich immer wieder wiederholenswert, dass es eben gar nicht erwartet werden kann von Menschen, die direkt betroffen werden, über diesen Schmerz hinaus zu denken. Wer soll diese Empathie haben? Wenn du sagst, dass du nach einer Woche schon so weit warst, da wieder anders drüber denken zu können, dann zeigt das schon, du aus welchen Gründen auch immer, du schaffst das, aber es ist nicht zu erwarten. Es ist aber wichtig von denen, die am Rand stehen und mit Entsetzen auf das Blicken was da passiert und dazu gehöre eben ich und dazu gehöre ganz viele Leute, die diese Sendung hören. Für uns ist es wichtig, das zu machen, was er gesagt hat. Don't be intellectually lazy, don't be emotionally lazy. Die einfachen Antworten, es gibt sie nicht. Es gibt nicht die eine Lösung. Es gibt auch nicht den einen Aggressor. Auf beiden Seiten passieren Menschenrechtsverletzungen und vor allem Menschenrechtsverletzungen können keine Begründung haben. So grauenhaft, alles war, was am 7. Oktober passiert ist, so grauenhaft sind viele Dinge, die jetzt gerade in Gaza passieren. Und da kann man jetzt immer noch erklären, der Klammern herum machen, dass das Kalkül der Hamas sein könnte, dass es auch schwierig ist, militärisch und so weiter und so fort. Aber an dem einfachen Fakt ändert sich trotzdem nichts. Und die einfachen Antworten gibt es nicht. Und ich sehe in auch meiner Bubble, in großen, in der linken Bubble, der ich mich auch zugehörig gefühlt habe, inzwischen gibt es da auch Menschen, wo ich das Gefühl habe, okay, anscheinend reicht das nicht an Übereinstimmung. Da sehe ich eben genau diese kognitive Faulheit, ehrlich gesagt, eben einfach eine Wahrheit als die wahre zu erkennen und sich dann klar zu positionieren. Und das ist aber gar nicht möglich. Jeder, der glaubt, eine eindeutige Position zu haben, der müsste sich, glaube ich, hinterfragen, weil er ganz sicher mindestens eine Seite nicht sieht. Anders kann es. Also ich habe so viele Podcasts und andere Dinge jetzt zu diesem Krieg und dem Konflikt gehört. Ich habe im Studium damals, ich habe ja Politikwissenschaften unter anderem studiert, ich habe extra ein Seminar belegt zum Nahostkonflikt, weil ich mir dachte, ich möchte den endlich verstehen. Ich kam raus aus diesem Seminar, sechs Monate lang haben wir da Lektüre um Lektüre gewälzt. Ich war am Schluss noch verwirrter, es war noch komplizierter. Also sprich, wenn ihr glaubt, ihr habt die eine einfache Lösung oder ihr seht den einen klaren Aggressor, dann seht ihr wahrscheinlich nicht genug von der anderen Seite. Und das in aller Abstraktheit wollte ich hier dann doch nochmal adressieren, weil ich glaube, dass das ein Grundproblem ist des aktuellen Diskurses oder manchmal kann man ihn ja nicht mal Diskurs nennen, im Fußball und darüber hinaus.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich wollte nur sagen, ich unterschreibe jedes Wort. Ich glaube, die Analyse von Juwan Naujah ist auch richtig. Ich glaube schon, dass die Aufgabe, vor allem aus politischer Sicht, aus emotionaler Sicht, bin ich nicht unbedingt immer noch nicht 100 Prozent in der Lage, darüber zu sprechen, was ich glaube, dass man in der Zukunft tun soll. Aber ich finde, dass als Anfang eine gute Idee tatsächlich diese Räume zu schaffen, wo man über Sachen sprechen könnte und wo man auch miteinander in Kontakt kommen könnte, weil es ist wirklich ganz absurd. Ich glaube, dieses Mal ist das ein bisschen anders, weil es so krass ist. Ich fand es aber in früheren Operationen und früheren Runden, wie wir sie auf Hebräisch nennen, dass die Menschen, die mich in dieser Gesellschaft am besten verstehen können, dass es andere Menschen gibt, die auch betroffen sind. Heißt, Israelis und jüdischen Juden, aber auch Leute, die palästinänische Wurzeln haben. Das sind die besten und emotionalsten Gespräche, die ich jedes Mal hatte, dass es passiert war. Und ich möchte, dass diese Möglichkeit weiterhin möglich sein wird, nachdem das Ganze vorbei sein wird. Ich möchte keine Realität haben, wo wir sagen, dieser Krieg, egal wie es endet, wird uns weiterhin voneinander wegnehmen. Egal wie emotional ich bin im Moment und egal wie wütend ich bin. Und das sind Sachen, die auf jeden Fall existieren. Aber realistisch betrachtet muss es irgendeine Zukunft haben, die nicht nur von Kriegen geprägt ist. Und dafür, wie gesagt, da unterschreibe ich hier das Wort für Menschen, die nicht involviert sind, also tatsächlich sich so viel zu informieren, wie möglich, zu verstehen, zumindest im Kopf, wenn nicht im Herzen, wie gerade den Menschen geht, vor allem emotional. Und damit einen Anfang geschaffen werden könnte, für die Zukunft auf jeden Fall.
Und das knüpft ja dann auch indirekt an das an, was wir ganz am Anfang im Intro gehört haben. Das war der letzte O-Ton von Joseph Schuster, dem Vorsitzenden des Zentralrats der Juden, zugegeben. Der kommt aus dem letzten Jahr, also da war mit dem 7. Oktober nicht zu rechnen. Aber wo er am Rande einer Veranstaltung eben zu Antisemitismus im Fußball und zu Programmen gegen Antisemitismus im Fußball, wo er sagt, er glaubt, der Fußball kann Teil der Lösung sein inzwischen. Früher war er Teil des Problems, jetzt könne er Teil der Lösung sein. Angesichts der aktuellen Entwicklungen, würdest du dem denn zustimmen?
Auf jeden Fall, also ich glaube schon, dass die Diskussion vor allem in Sachen aktive Fanszenen, vor allem europatechnisch, aber europaweit ist die Diskussion so gespaltet, dass ich es schon schwierig finde, gerade über Lösungen zu sprechen. Ich glaube aber schon, dass wenn es eines gibt, was diese Zeit bewiesen hat aus der deutschen Fußballperspektive, ist, dass Begegnungen zwischen Menschen auch zu Verständnis und auch emotionalem Verständnis führen. Ich kann nur sagen, eine Geschichte aus meinem Leben, am 7. Oktober, nachdem ich herausgefunden habe, dass meine Schwester und ihre Kinder in Sicherheit sind, dachte ich mir, okay, ich gucke einen terroristischen Anschlag, das ist wirklich unprecedented sozusagen, ich kann aber kaum sagen, dass das Verständnis bei mir war, dass es wirklich so ein Event, was mein ganzes Leben prägen wird. Im Endeffekt war das 9.11 hoch 3, für Israel, ist wirklich so. Aber an dem Tag habe ich das nicht so richtig verstanden, weil du gerade in der Situation bist. Ich habe an dem Tag, ich glaube abends oder nachts sogar, da hat mir ein Freund aus der Ultraszene von Werder Bremen eine Nachricht geschrieben und hat gefragt, wie es dir geht? Was brauchst du? Wie kann ich dich unterstützen? Also sehr viele Fragen von einem Menschen, der merkt, da gibt es jemanden, der in einer Krise ist. In dieser Krise war ich, ich habe es aber noch nicht verstanden. Dieser Mensch kommt aus einer Ultra-Gruppe, die eine enge Freundschaft mit einer israelischen Ultra-Gruppe hat. Und dieser Mensch hat das von außen emotional besser verstanden als ich. Und das ist alles durch enge Begegnungen zwischen den zwei Seiten. Und danke dir an dieser Stelle, du weißt, wer du bist. Und diese Begegnung könnte durch den Fußball auch zwischen den Seiten dem Konflikt stattfinden. Auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, wir haben in Deutschland Fußballvereine wie Maccabi, wo Muslime und Juden zusammenspielen. Und das ist eigentlich alles cool zwischen denen. Wir haben Ultra-Gruppen, die im Bereich politische Aufklärungsarbeit aktiv sind, die sehr, sehr gute Arbeit leisten. In Städten wie München, Bremen, Hamburg und und und. Die Liste ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr lang, zum Glück. Und das sind alles Themen, die auch zwei Seiten nach vorne bringen können, die gerade in einem Konflikt stehen. Und das würde ich mir wünschen, auf jeden Fall, dass der Fußball und die Fankultur auch diese Rolle spielen werden. In der vorsehbaren Zukunft ist das jetzt wirklich unvorstellbar durch den Ausmaß der Situation. Aber in der vorsehbaren Zukunft möchte ich mir nur hoffen, dass der Fußball und auch der deutschen Fußball übrigens diese Rolle wahrnehmen und einnehmen werden.
Wobei du da natürlich immer sehr von den Fanszenen her denkst, weil du da selber so aktiv bist. Und jetzt ist ja nur ein Teil der Menschen, die sich für Fußball interessieren, in Fanszenen aktiv oder fühlt sich denen gar zugehörig. Was glaubst du denn, kann darüber hinaus passieren, eben aus den Fanszenen heraus? Wie zum Beispiel beurteilst du den Umgang, jetzt bleibt man mal in Deutschland, dann würde ich schon auch gerne noch mal aufs Internationale blicken, das hast du ja auch schon angedeutet. Wie fandest du denn den Umgang des deutschen Fußballs mit dem Anschlag und dem danach?
Ich werde das unterscheiden, es ist mir sehr wichtig, zu sagen, dass die Wahrnehmung in Israel bezüglich des deutschen Fußballs, vor allem durch die Aktionen der aktiven Fanszenen, oder vor allem durch Aktionen von aktiven Fanszenen, wie Werder Bremen, wie der FC St. Pauli, wie Chemie Leipzig und andere. Gerade fühlen sich israelische Fußballfans, dass der deutsche Fußball der einzige in Europa, der an der Seite steht. Viele Menschen sagen, es gibt so Twitter-Threads auf Hebräisch, so hilft mir, meinen deutschen Verein zu wählen, so nach dem Motto.
Oh Gott, hoffentlich liest es nicht der israelische FC Augsburg-Fanclub, von dem du mal erzählt hast. Es gibt drei Fanclubs von Bundesligisten Bayern, Dortmund und natürlich Augsburg in Israel.
Natürlich, selbstverständlich. Ich glaube, dass die FC Augsburg-Fans in Israel tatsächlich fest verwurzelt sind in ihrem Verein. Das brauchen sie tatsächlich. Einen neuen Verein brauchen sie nicht. Aber diese Diskussionen zeigen, dass dieses Zeichen, das gesetzt worden ist, durch die Fans sind und auch durch einige Vereine, muss man sagen. Fan-Kultur ist mein Bereich und ich spreche darüber sehr gerne, aber im Endeffekt gab es auch Vereine, die sehr gute Reaktionen gezeigt haben. Man könnte Borussia Dortmund nennen. Ich bin sehr froh, dass auch mein Verein eine gute Reaktion gezeigt hat, der FC Köln und Werder Bremen sowieso und und und. Das kommt an in Israel und ich glaube, das ist gerade viel wichtiger als alles, was ich sagen würde. Weil das die Menschen sind, die gerade betroffen sind. Das die Menschen sind, die gerade wie Juval noch gesagt hat, die gerade so tief in ihrer Trauer stecken, dass sie gerade an nichts anderem denken können. Und das muss man sagen. Der zweite Teil ist tatsächlich der Teil mir, der sich tatsächlich mit dem deutschen Fußball auseinandersetzt. Ich finde die Reaktion des deutschen Fußballs prinzipiell sehr, sehr gut. Und ich fand es sehr gut, dass es auch in einigen der Statements nicht vergessen worden ist, dass es unschuldige Menschen auch in Gaza gibt. Finde ich auch richtig anzumerken. Ich fände auf jeden Fall, ich sag mal so Aufmerksamkeit durch den Fußball gut. Ich meine, der FC St. Pauli hat das so aufgerufen, Geld zu spenden an die Anschuldiger Menschen in Gaza, was ich auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr gut finde. Und es ist aber auch so, dass diese, ich sag mal so, die Elemente, die das vorantreiben, das sind tatsächlich vor allem die Fans und die Mitglieder der Vereine. Und das zeigt mir persönlich zum Beispiel, wie wichtig das Thema 50 plus 1 ist. In England ist das übrigens überhaupt nicht so. In England versucht man irgendwen da mit zu stehen. Keine Politik im Stadion sagt die Premier League selbst. Das sage nicht nur ich. Es gab einen Vorfall, der den israelischen Fußballfesten total geschockt hat. Ein sehr bekannter israelischer Liverpool-Fan, Roy Munda. Man kann das hier auf YouTube sehen. Ich bin eher auf meiner United-Seite geschichtlich betrachtet. Aber es ist wirklich bei dem Thema total egal. Roy Munda war ein sehr bekannter FC Liverpool-Fan in Israel. Er ist regelmäßig nach Liverpool gereist, um seinen Verein zu sehen. Er wurde von der Hamas ermordet. Einige Leute aus dem israelischen Liverpool-Fan-Club wollten eine Fahne ins Stadion bringen, mit dem Bild von Roy Munda und den Bildern von zwei anderen Liverpool-Fans, die ermordet worden sind. Im Übrigen ist der Bruder von Roy Munda neun Jahre alt, auch Liverpool-Fan. Neun Jahre alt und der ist gerade als Geisel in Gaza. Es gab an dem Tag, das war das Derby gegen Everton, meine ich, und da kam ein Ordner zu dem Typen, der die Fahne aufgehängt hat, und da haben wir gesagt, das ist zu politisch. Das kommt jetzt runter. Und das würde in Deutschland, wenn sowas in Deutschland passieren würde, gäbe es so einen Aufschrei aus Seiten der Fenster, wo man zumindest die Vorstellung hat, natürlich ist das passiert, aber es gibt auch jemanden an meiner Seite. Im Falle Liverpool ist das überhaupt nicht so. Liverpool ist gerade das Symbol dafür, wie große internationale Vereine den Israelis alleine gelassen haben. So sehen das Israelis. Und im Vergleich dazu ist der deutsche Fußball in einem, der deutsche Fußball hat einen besonderen Platz im Herzen der Israelis nach dem 7. Oktober wegen der Reaktion auf Seiten der Fanszene und aus der Seite Mannschaftsvereine. Und es wird sich zeigen, wie es sich entwickelt tatsächlich. Also ich möchte nur eine letzte Geschichte erzählen, was damit zu tun hat. Ich bin zwar 1. FC Köln-Mitglied und Fan, ich bin aber in sehr engem Kontakt mit dem israelischen Fanclub von Borussia Dortmund. Das sind gute Leute, gute Freundinnen von mir. Und diese Leute haben dafür gesorgt, dass 14 Überlebenden des Massakres aus den Kibbutzim in der Nähe des Gazastreifens nach Deutschland hinfliegen würden und das Spiel gegen den FC Bayern sehen würden, im Westfalenstadion. Ich weiß, dass es auch einiges an Support gab für diese Gruppe. Finanzielles Support und auch andere Arten von Support von Borussia Dortmund, um das Verleib dieser Menschen in Deutschland so ablenkend zu machen wie möglich. Ein Satz, den ich nie vergessen werde, einer der Mitglieder in dieser Gruppe, der ist 14, der hat seinen Bruder und seinen Vater verloren im Angriff. Nach den Aktivitäten, die er in Deutschland erlebt hat und nachdem er im Westfalen-Stadion war, hat er der Mutter von ihm gesagt, Mama, siehst du, ich bin glücklich. Das ist wirklich 2,5 Wochen nachdem man seinen Bruder und seinen Vater verloren hat, in der wirklich grausamsten möglichen Wege. Diese Geschichte erzählt alles, wie die Wahrnehmung in Israel bezüglich des deutschen Fußballs ist.
Und wie denkst du über Symbolik? Denn logischerweise können viele der Worte, die man dann absendet, die müssen in erster Instanz erstmal symbolisch bleiben. Und dann hat ja die DFL, hat sich entschieden, den 36 Profiklubs eine Schweigeminute zu empfehlen, aber die Ausgestaltung hat jeder Verein anders gemacht. Und da gab es dann auch Vereine, die auf die zivilen Opfer auf beiden Seiten zum Beispiel hingewiesen haben. Es gab aber auch welche, die sich orientiert haben an der Leitlinie der DFL. Ist das den Vereinen vorzuwerfen, dass es über Symbolik oft ja dann doch nicht hinausgeht? Du hast jetzt ja eine Ausnahme erzählt mit dem BVB-Beispiel. Aber was würdest du dir da erhoffen? Jetzt vielleicht auch in der weiteren Entwicklung dieses Krieges, der er ja ist?
Ich sag mal so, eines vorab, wir haben das schon gesagt, dieser Konflikt ist unfassbar kompliziert. Ich erwarte von keinem Verein in Deutschland den Nahuskonflikt zu lösen. Und auch da keine, ja, also ich erwarte das von einem Fußballverein nicht. Andererseits haben wir auch gesagt, dass ich von Seiten, die nicht involviert sind, dass ich mir hoffe, dass die damit so umgehen würden, dass auch diese Räume geschaffen werden für die betroffenen Menschen, Israelis, PalästinenserInnen, miteinander zu reden danach. Und da glaube ich, hat der Fußball schon eine große Rolle, vor allem für eine, die international gut unterstützt sind, nämlich Borussia Dortmund und Bayern München. Das sind Vereine, die zum Beispiel auch Fanclubs in der arabischen Welt haben. Das sind Vereine, die auch in Israel sehr viele Fans haben, sehr viele jüdische Fans im Ausland auch, in den USA nämlich. Ich kenne einige Fans von Bayern München, von Borussia Dortmund, die auch jüdisch sind. Und diese Räume zu schaffen, ich würde nicht sagen, dass es die Aufgabe der Vereine ist. Aber es würde mich freuen, wenn der Fußball diese Rolle wahrnehmen würde. Weil ich glaube, Deutschland als Land, als politisches Konstrukt, ich sage mal so, ein Land an sich triggert bei Menschen nur begrenzte Emotionen. Vor allem ein Land wie Deutschland, überall bekannt ist und so weiter. Fußball aber hat eine sehr, sehr starke emotionale Kraft. Und darüber reden wir hier. Wir reden über Leute, die krass emotional involviert sind. Und die haben wirklich keine Kapazitäten, an nichts anderem zu denken, außer zu überleben ist. Und diese hohe Emotionalität des Fußballs könnte auch dazu benutzt werden, diese Räume zu schaffen. Und das würde ich mir wünschen. Wie man es tut, glaube ich, es gibt schon einige Kräfte im deutschen Fußball, die sich mit Bildung durch Fußball auseinandersetzen und so weiter. Aber generell würde ich es mir auf jeden Fall wünschen.
Ich meine, es ist alles andere als eine leichte Situation, auch für die Fußballvereine. Ich weiß zum Beispiel von Bundesligisten, die über sehr klare Positionierungen nachgedacht haben. Und dann aber auch angesichts des Attentats auf die zwei schwedischen Fußballfans bei ihrem Auswärtsspiel in Belgien. Da war es, glaube ich, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere, davor zurückgestreckt, weil sie Angst hatten, selbst zu zielen, solcher Attacken zu werden. Und wem sollte man das vorwerfen? Von wem wollen wir das fordern, dass man das jetzt wirklich macht? Gleichzeitig haben wir aber natürlich auch, oder was heißt natürlich, es ist zumindest meiner Meinung nach zu beobachten, dass es eine gewisse Asymmetrie gibt. Und die gibt es aber auf verschiedenen Ebenen und in verschiedenen Bereichen. Und zwar einerseits, und das klingt jetzt, glaube ich, ganz schlimm, was ich sage. Ich hoffe, dass ich es dann noch verständlich machen kann. Also wir hatten jetzt zum Beispiel im 07. Oktober eine Schweigeminute. Wäre es dann jetzt nicht auch ein gutes Zeichen, jetzt dann auch eine Schweigeminute für die Zivilopfer in Gaza? Und übrigens ja auch im Westjordanland. Da ist es nur schlechter dokumentiert aus verschiedenen Gründen. Aber da passieren gerade auch Menschenrechtsverletzungen. Ich glaube, man kann das so allgemein doch formulieren. Wäre das nicht zum Beispiel jetzt dann auch angemessen, um nämlich genau auf diese Dichotomie hinzuweisen, dass es keine klare Positionierung gibt, sondern wir stehen an der Seite von beiden Opfern?
Ich sage mal so. Ich werde meine Antwort zu zwei Teilen, weil ich glaube, dass es schon wichtig ist. Es gibt einen grundsätzlichen, wie gesagt, meine Antwort wäre tatsächlich damit, es ist mir immer sehr wichtig, auch meinen Bias zu zeigen. Ich bin gerade in dieser emotionalen Situation drin. Ich komme aus Israel, ich kenne Menschen, die umgebracht worden sind. Das Thema ist für mich höchst emotional. Trotzdem muss man sagen, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen Leuten, die gestorben sind in einem Krieg zwischen zwei bewaffneten Seiten und Menschen, die abgeschlachtet wurden, weil sie jüdisch sind. Da gibt es einen Unterschied. Menschenleben ist Menschenleben. Es gibt trotzdem in der Wahrnehmung der Menschen einen kleinen Unterschied, vor allem in der Wahrnehmung der Menschen in der westlichen Welt, die eher ein Ziel von Terrorismus sein können, möglicherweise als ein Ziel von einem Krieg. Das ist halt so, muss man ganz klar ansprechen. Ich finde es aber auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig, auch die zivile Opfer der Palästinenser zu erwähnen, in eigenem Kontext. Ich finde es auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig, darüber zu sprechen, dass es im Westjordanland Menschenrechtsverletzungen gibt. Dass es auch innerhalb von Israel Probleme gibt, ob es die Rolle des durchschnittlichen Fußballklubs in Deutschland ist, weiß ich persönlich nicht. Ich glaube schon, dass man zumindest auf einer –wie soll ich das sagen –auch auf oberflächlicher Ebene das anzusprechen, wie zum Beispiel zu sagen, Geld sammeln für die zivile Opfer in Gaza oder für UNRWA oder von wem weiß ich. Das würde ich mir schon wünschen, weil auch in Gaza gibt es Opfer. Und natürlich gibt es in Gaza auch die Hamas. Und ich hätte prinzipiell kein Problem damit, dass jede Person, die der Hamas zugehörig ist, nicht mehr da wäre. Ich sage es, wie es ist. Ich bin wütend. Und das sind wir viele Menschen, glaube ich, aus der Ecke. Und trotzdem bedeutet das nicht, dass jeder Mensch in Gaza schuld ist, dass die Hamas an der Macht ist. Ich meine, das letzte Mal, dass es Wahlen in Gaza gab, war 2006. Also viele Menschen, die gerade ums Leben kommen, konnten das nicht wählen. Und ja, viele Menschen in Gaza unterstützen die Hamas. Das ist halt so. Und trotzdem ist Unterstützung für eine Organisation nicht gleich Zugehörigkeit der Organisation. Es gab eine Diskussion zwischen mir und meinem Bruder vor zwei, drei Wochen, direkt nachdem es ein bisschen mehr Beweise gibt in den Medien. Und der eine Beweis aus dem 7. Oktober war, dass ein Zivilist aus Gaza seine Mutter angerufen hat und hat erzählt, wie er zehn Juden abgeschlachtet hat mit seinen Händen. Die Mutter hat sich total gefreut und was weiß ich, kommt nach Hause, die hat geweint vor Freude und und und. Mein Bruder hat mir gefragt, weil wir die ganze Zeit darüber sprechen, wer das verdient hat, im Krieg zu sterben oder nicht. Meiner Meinung nach sind Hamas Leute das Ziel, aber Menschen, auch die Hamas unterstützen, aber nichts getan haben, das sind keine legitimen Ziele für mich persönlich. Und dann war die Frage, was hältst du von dieser Frau? Ist sie unschuldig, in Anführungsstrichen, oder hat sie es verdient zu sterben? Ich habe gesagt, komplizierte Frage auf jeden Fall, aber im Endeffekt hat sie nichts getan. Ihr Sohn hat Menschen ermordet, und was mit ihrem Sohn passieren wird, von mir aus kann der Sohn alles Schlimmste erleben auf der Erde. Das wird mir auf gar keinen Fall leid tun. Aber die Mutter, die kann, selbst wenn sie sich freut, nach dem Juden ermordet worden sind, heißt für mich persönlich nicht, dass sie es verdient hat zu sterben. Wegen sowas. Das heißt nicht, dass sie schuldig ist. Und das ist gerade die Diskussion, die stattfindet, in vielen Kreisen in Israel. Es gibt teilweise auch eine Art Entmenschlichung der Menschen in Gaza, was ich auf gar keinen Fall gut finde. Und was ich immer kritisieren werde, egal wie hoch emotional das Thema für mich ist. Und es ist aber sehr, sehr kompliziert, als Fußballverein darauf zu reagieren, muss man fairerweise sagen. Ich fand auch die Reaktion der Fußballvereine in Deutschland bezüglich des 7. Oktober relativ oberflächlich. Ich meine, es ist nicht so, dass jemand Geld gesammelt hat oder eine Art Delegation nach Israel geschickt hat und jeden Tag nur darüber postet. Die haben ihre Solidarität bekündigt. Und in der Regel war das alles. Und diese Solidarität verdienen auch die unschuldigen Menschen in Gaza. Da bin ich bei dir. Wie man damit umgeht, habe ich wirklich keine Ahnung. Es ist eine komplizierte Situation. Ich fand aber persönlich den Umgang des 1. St. Pauli damit sehr, sehr gut, dass man gesagt hat, wir haben zwar viele Freundinnen bei HaPolizeiLaviv, die getroffen sind, das sind befreundet, die zwei Ultra-Gruppen. Aber es ist wichtig anzumerken, es gibt auch Menschen in Gaza, die unschuldig sind und gerade von der Situation betroffen sind. Man könnte denen so helfen, diese Organisation ist da aktiv und und und. Finde ich total in Ordnung. Und so könnte man damit umgehen auf jeden Fall. Weil wie gesagt, der Fußball hat diese Kraft, Menschen zu informieren über Themen, die sie nicht schon mitbekommen haben davor. Und auch Auseinandersetzungen fast zu zwingen, wenn du siehst, dass dein Verein über sowas spricht. Da musst du dich damit auseinandersetzen. Aus der emotionalen Verbindung zum Verein heraus. Und deswegen halte ich das für sehr wichtig, dass Vereine da einen Weg finden würden, aktiv zu sein.
Ja, eben weil sie gerade auch in der arabischen Welt so eine hohe Reichweite haben, zumindest manche Vereine. Und man hat es ja bisher immer an Themen gemerkt, die ein bisschen leichter auszuhalten waren, weil es nicht direkt um Mord und Totschlag ging auf beiden Seiten. Also wenn du eben mal beobachten konntest, wie deutsche Accounts, also die in den deutschsprachigen Versionen der sozialen Netzwerke dann zum Beispiel Regenbogen fahren und so weiter, im Pride Month und so weiter gepostet haben, und dann hast du geguckt, was habt ihr denn auf euren arabischen Netzwerken gemacht? Ach so, nichts. Okay, warum denn eigentlich das? Und das ist natürlich per se auch schon nicht gut, denn das ist auch eine Art der Bigotterie. Aber es geht eben noch nicht direkt um Mord und Totschlag. Und gleichzeitig habe ich das Gefühl, also allein, dass wir uns in einer Situation befinden, wo du ernsthaft als, und ich werfe dir das nicht vor, aber wo du ernsthaft darüber sprichst, wer den Tod verdient hat, wo ich als Unbeteiligter auf der Beobachter-Ebene 2 sagen kann, niemand hat den Tod verdient, nicht eigentlich, weil es liegt gar nicht an uns, das zu entscheiden. Aber allein das zeigt ja schon, wie fatal diese Situation geworden ist und wie tiefgreifend sie auch in unsere Emotionen reingreift. Und da habe ich mir dann schon die Frage gestellt, und ich weiß, dass sich das von außen leicht sagt, ob der Fußball da nicht eigentlich ansetzen müsste. Denn wir haben ja vorhin schon erzählt, der Fußball ist ein sozialer Ort im Stadion, auf dem Weg dahin usw. Und wo sonst in der Gesellschaft begegnen sich so viele unterschiedliche Menschen, unterschiedlichster gesellschaftlicher Gruppen, ethnischer Zugehörigkeit usw. wie auch immer du die Töpfe jetzt formen willst, in die du die einzelnen Menschen dann als Erbsen reinwürfst. Und jetzt haben wir zum Beispiel so etwas wie den Fall Masrawi. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir nochmal genau in die Details einsteigen müssen, weil das auch Becker und Pfeiffer haben das ganz wunderbar nochmal herausgearbeitet in ihrem Podcast und es wurde auch sehr viel darüber berichtet. Aber wir haben ja beim FC Bayern die interessante Situation, dass wir nicht nur nur nur nur Sia Masrawi haben, sondern wir haben auch Daniel Perez, den israelischen U21-Nationaltorhüter, der dafür, dass er ja direkt betroffen ist, ein bemerkenswertes Video gepostet hat, wo man auch gesehen hat, wie reflektiert sich Menschen auch äußern können in sozialen Netzwerken. Und müsste jetzt nicht vielleicht, auch wenn es extrem schwierig ist für alle Beteiligten, der nächste Punkt sein zu versuchen mit Masrawi, da gab es eben die Gespräche, er hat sich auch schon mit der israelischen Kultusgemeinde hier in München getroffen, Charlotte Knoblauch, über was da besprochen wurde, ist nicht ganz klar. Geht uns vielleicht auch nichts an, ich bin mir da noch nicht so ganz sicher. Aber wenn du doch diese beiden Spieler in deinem Team hast und damit ja auch im Grunde diesen Konflikt bei dir im Team hast und du auch weißt, welche große Bedeutung du hast, ich meine, es wurde zeitweise nur noch über El Ghazi von Mainz 5 und über Masrawi gesprochen und wie mit ihm umgegangen wird, müsste man das nicht eigentlich nutzen und jetzt diese beiden zusammenbringen und das nach außen hin leben, was der Fußball immer behauptet. Der Fußball behauptet immer, in der Kabine spielt es keine Rolle, wo jemand herkommt, wem er angehört, welche Religion er hat. Hier sind wir El-Freunde in Anführungszeichen. Wäre das nicht eigentlich eine riesige Chance, das jetzt zu tun, wenn die beiden Protagonisten das wollen? Ich will hier niemanden da reinzwingen.
Der letzte Satz ist tatsächlich der Schlüsselsatz hier, finde ich. Wie gesagt, zur Erinnerung, genau, was wir gesagt haben früher, sehr viele Menschen sind in diesem Krieg auch direkt betroffen. Daniel Beretz ist direkt betroffen. Daniel Beretz ist ein anderer Fußballfigur. Daniel Beretz ist auf jeden Fall, ich meine, auch persönlich betroffen. Also, der kennt einige Menschen, die ermordet worden sind, glaube ich. Wenn ich in Israel richtig gelesen habe. Andererseits würde Masrawi meinen. Das Thema Palästina ist mir auch wichtig. Wie gesagt, das sind Muslime und. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Emotionen da so hochspielen. Und das wäre, glaube ich, schon unfair, den Menschen gegenüber zu sagen, setzt euch setzt euch jetzt miteinander und zeigt der Kamera, dass alles cool ist. Das wäre nicht richtig. Ich glaube schon, dass es. Ich sag mal so, der Fußball hat diese Kraft. Aber der hat diese Kraft vor allem durch die, ich sag mal, organischen Entwicklung, die er verursachen könnte. Es ist nicht so, dass wenn Bayern München jetzt sagen würde, kommt, setzt vor der Kamera, spricht miteinander und zeigt, dass alles mega cool ist. Es ist nicht so, dass es wirklich was bringen würde, wenn man direkt sagen würde, naja, der Verein hat gesagt, die bekommen Schweine viel Geld vom Verein. Natürlich werden die das machen. Es wäre aber was total anderes, wenn die zwei sich tatsächlich miteinander sprechen und mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen und von sich alleine was kommen würde. Dann wäre das ein ganz anderes Signal. Und sowas kann der Fußball herstellen auf jeden Fall. Ich finde aber schon, dass es auch gar nicht sein muss, dass kein Verein jetzt kommen könnte und sagen könnte, hier sind alle befreundet, alles ist cool, wie eine Tele-Tabis-Folge oder so. Das ist nicht realistisch und das kommt auch nicht glaubwürdig an. Ich finde schon, wie gesagt, solange der Fußball helfen würde, diese Räume zu schaffen, werde ich diese Räume schaffen, wo Menschen miteinander begegnen, miteinander sprechen und im Übrigen nicht unbedingt, nicht nur in Sachen Konflikt Israel-Palästina, sondern auch hier in der deutschen Gesellschaft, wo Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund, mit Menschen in Kontakt kommen, die noch kein einziges Mal eine Person of Color gesehen haben. In meinem Fall, viele Menschen, die ich aus der Kurve kenne, haben mir am Anfang gesagt, du bist der erste jüdische Mensch, den wir kennenlernen. Und durch den Fußball werden solche Connections tatsächlich geschafft. Und das ist auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig und ein wichtiger Teil meiner Leidenschaft zu den Fußball. Aber es muss auch gar nicht passieren. Und es muss nicht bezwungen werden. Das wäre noch fataler meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, das ist völlig richtig. Ich möchte kurz darauf hinweisen, wenn wir jetzt noch lange weitersprechen, verpasst du dein Fußballspiel? Sollen wir unterbrechen?
Ja, es geht klar, macht dir keine Sorge. Also am schlimmsten Fall komme ich zu den zweiten 45 Minuten. Alles ist okay. Also ich finde dieses Gespräch tatsächlich viel wichtiger.
Dann lasse ich das auch so drin. Aber dann lass doch noch mal kurz über Masrawi und auch Anwar El Ghazi sprechen. Denn wir haben ja auch im Intro, haben wir Alan Meyer gehört, den Vorsitzenden von Makabi Deutschland. Das ist eben der Dachverband für alle Makabi-Vereine, in denen aber, du hast es ja vorhin richtig auch schon gesagt, das sind keine jüdischen Vereine. Da spielen alle möglichen Religionen mit. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob man da wirklich bei einer U9, bei den Kindern jetzt von Religion sprechen muss. Die spielen einfach nur Fußball, aber nach außen hin eben mit dem jüdischen Antlitz. Weil Makabi kommt, du hast das auch mal erklärt in einem der Podcasts, letztlich kommt das auch aus einer Strömung des Zionismus, dieses Wort Makabi.
Genau. Also kurze Erklärung. Makabi sind schon jüdische Vereine, also Vereine mit jüdischer Identität. Aber in diesen Vereinen können alle mitmachen. Wenn, was weiß ich, ein Kind Fußball spielen möchte, dann kommt er, dann wird man Mitglied in einem Verein und dann spielt man Fußball. Es ist egal, ob das Kind jüdisch ist oder nicht. Und die letzte Statistik, die ich habe, ist, dass, glaube ich, weniger als 40 Prozent der Sportlerinnen bei Makabi jüdisch sind oder eine Verbindung haben zum Jugendtum. Also es ist ein komplexes Bild, aber es muss auch so erzählt werden.
Genau, das sind über 4500 Vereine, glaube ich, inzwischen, die man hat. Nee, Spieler, Entschuldigung, so ist es richtig, die bei Makabi Deutschland spielen. Und er hat gesagt, das haben wir vorhin im Intro gehört, das war der Ausschnitt aus dem aktuellen Sportstudio, dass er enttäuscht sei von der Reaktion des FC Bayern, der eben auf das Posting von Masrawi dann mit einer Pressemitteilung reagiert hat, in der der FC Bayern sehr, sehr viele Punkte gemacht hat. Und aber wenn man darauf geachtet hat, Masrawi konnte manche Punkte, wie eben zum Beispiel eine Distanzierung von der Hamas, so schwer sie vielleicht auch fallen mag, es fällt mir schwer, mich da hineinzusetzen. Aber das hat in jedem Fall gefehlt. Teilst du diese Enttäuschung, die Alon Maier da artikuliert hat, in sehr deutlichen Worten?
Auf persönlicher Ebene schon ein bisschen, aber auf beruflicher Ebene, was mit dem, also auf journalistischer Ebene, muss man auch realistisch sein. Ich glaube schon, dass es da einen ziemlich starken Unterschied gibt zwischen dem Fall Masraoui und dem Fall des Mainzer Spielers. Und im Falle Masraoui gab es eine Äußerung an dem Tag des Massakres, die ich schon problematisch fand. Andererseits muss man sagen, ich habe nicht das Gefühl gehabt, dass es irgendwie total Grenzen überschreitet, wie in anderen Fällen. Man muss sagen, Fußballspieler sind Menschen. Menschen haben politische Meinungen. Und dieser Meinungen sollen sie sich äußern können. Dass man sich mit Palästina solidarisiert. Ja, der Zeitpunkt war mehr als unglücklich, ich sag mal so. Und wirklich, ich spreche hier wirklich aus der Emotion heraus. Aber realistisch betrachtet gab es ein Gespräch mit dem Verein. Es gab ein Gespräch mit der israelitischen Kultusgemeinde Nünchen. Der hat sich zumindest nach außen damit auseinandergesetzt. Dann kam die Stellungnahme des Vereins, die ich auch eher so miterfinde. Aber alles in allem finde ich den Umgang des FC Bayern damit relativ verständlich. Selbst wenn viele Menschen aus der jüdischen Bubble das nicht richtig finden würden, finde ich das schon richtig. Es ist nicht so, dass die politische Meinung von Spielern in Sachen Solidarität mit Palästina total kriminalisiert werden soll. Das finde ich auch nicht cool. Das sind Menschen, die haben Meinungen. Auch wenn dieser Meinung nicht unbedingt vieler Meinungen hier in Deutschland entspricht, ist das trotzdem ihre Meinung und die hat ihre Daseinsberechtigung, solange sie bestimmte Grenzen nicht überschreitet.
Und das ist der Unterschied zu El-Gazi.
Beim Fall El-Gazi war es tatsächlich eine Grenzenüberschreitung und eine klare Grenzenüberschreitung. Das mit dem Sight from the River to the Sea und mit diesem ominösen Hinweis, als ob Israel alles erfindet, mit künstlicher Intelligenz benutzen, um Sachen zu verleugnen oder sowas. Das ist schon so verschwörungstheoretisch. Es geht schon in eine Richtung, die weit über die Grenze hinausgeht. Auch seine Reaktion nach der Suspendierung von ihm hat das gezeigt. Er versteht nicht, was das Problem ist. Er hat sich damit nicht auseinandergesetzt. Von daher finde ich den Umgang von Mainz damit auch richtig, dass man gesagt hat, das ist eine klare Linie, das geht nicht. Entweder setzt du dich mit dem Thema auseinander oder du bist raus. Masraoui hat sich entschieden, ich treffe mich mit Jüdinnen und Juden in München. Ich spreche mit denen. Wie gesagt, die Inhalte wissen wir nicht. Aber dieses Gespräch gab es zu mir. Im Falle Al-Ghazi gab es nicht mal das. Er hat gesagt, das ist meine Meinung. Ich stehe hinter Aussagen wie From the River to the Sea und wie Israel erfindet, Israel lügt mit künstlicher Intelligenz. Oder was weiß ich, wenn man hinter so etwas steht, dann ist es wirklich, wirklich uncool. Und da muss was getan werden aus Vereinsseite. Wie gesagt, ich fand den Umgang, nicht nur den Umgang vom FC Bayern, soweit wie es okay sein könnte in dieser Situation, ich fand den Umgang von Mainz richtig, richtig stabil, muss man sagen. Das ist kein großer, reicher Verein, der Geld ohne Ende hat. Das ist ein Spieler, den der Verein vor kurzem verpflichtet hat. Und trotzdem war der Verein stabil und hat gesagt, es ist uns in dem Fall egal, wir machen was richtig ist. Und das finde ich persönlich sehr gut. Und auch das kam übrigens sehr, sehr gut an mit Israel. Also man hat gesehen, es gibt Menschen, die uns sehen, selbst wenn es, ich sage mal so, wie viele Jüdinnen und Juden gibt es in Mainz, echt weniger. Und trotzdem hat der Verein sich entschieden, so zu handeln. Und das ist ein Zeichen für viele Leute in Israel und auch in der jüdischen Welt. So nach dem Motto, jemand denkt an uns selbst, wenn wir nicht da sind. Und das ist auch wichtig zu sagen.
Weil aber auch ja tatsächlich das, was da gepostet wurde, inzwischen eindeutig verbrieft. Vorher war es ein bisschen uneindeutig behandelt von verschiedenen Staatsanwaltschaften in Städten. Aber das ist strafrechtlich relevant. Da gibt es auch eine eingeleitete Untersuchung. Und seit, wir nehmen jetzt auf, am 10. November und seit heute 15 Uhr, da hat die SZ exklusiv bekannt gegeben, dass mit dem Verbot der Hamas eben auch genau die, eigentlich würde ich sie jetzt am liebsten gar nicht wiederholen, aber du hast ja auch schon gesagt, from the river to the sea, also vom Fluss bis zum Meer, Palästina wird frei sein, Palästina will be free. Das spricht Israel das Existenzrecht ab. Diese Formulierung, das funktioniert nur, wenn es Israel nicht gibt, genauso wie es auch auf anderer Seite auf Israel manchmal auch Darstellung gibt, in den Gaza-Untersprächen oder?
Das wollte ich gerade sagen, dass es auch erwähnt werden muss, dass Israel manchmal in offiziellen Karten das komplette Territorium vom Fluss bis zum Meer verwendet. Und das muss auch mehr kritisiert werden aus politischen Kreisen in Deutschland, muss ich ganz klar sagen. Aber ich sage mal so, die viel verbreitete Reversion ist from the river to the sea. Palestine will be free. Das muss man gesagt werden. Das muss man klar sagen und benennen. Ich finde auch, dass der Kontext eine andere ist. Der Kontext, in dem Palästina frei, in Anführungsstrichen, der ist im Kontext von entweder Vertreibung von jüdischen Menschen, oder man nimmt von denen das Recht der Selbstdetermination, das hat einen Namen auf Deutsch, den ich vergessen habe. Selbstdeterminierung, danke. Oder man behandelt sie, wie sie von der Hamas behandelt worden sind. Also das ist auch der Kontext dazu. Und der Kontext der PalästinenserInnen sind tatsächlich die Menschenrechtsverletzungen, die da stattfinden. Ich vergleiche die zwei nicht, das sind total andere Umstände, total andere Realitäten, die nicht vergleichbar sind aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Aber das sind die Realitäten auf beiden Seiten. Und man muss sagen, die Version, die viel verbreitet ist hier in Deutschland, ist die Version mit Palästina. Und das muss man auch klar benennen.
Ja, das bringt mich nämlich zu einem weiteren Punkt, den ich gerne mit dir besprechen wollen würde. Und zwar dem Antisemitismus, der in Deutschland, den es immer schon gab, auch nicht nur in Deutschland, aber nun leben wir mal hier und fühlen uns dafür eher verantwortlich, aber auch im Fußball. Denn da habe ich das Gefühl, dass jetzt hier noch so eine zweite Ebene mit reinkommt, die wir bisher noch nicht so gestreift haben. Bisher haben wir es ganz gut geschafft, uns beide zu abstrahieren und zu sagen, wo sind Symbole, die wirken so und so und könnte man nicht so noch ein Zeichen setzen. Gleichzeitig passieren aber ja gerade auch Taten. Und diese Taten sind mehrheitlich, zumindest das ist jetzt die Erfahrung, die ich durch meine Medienkonsum mache und durch mein persönliches Umfeld, antisemitisch. Und das haben wir ja auch im Intro gehört, dass eben manche, also manche Makabi-Vereine haben den Spielbetrieb gerade eingestellt. Viele trainieren nur unter Bewachung und dass in Deutschland Synagogen polizeilich bewacht werden, schon seit vielen, vielen Jahrzehnten, ist ja eigentlich an sich schon eine Absurdität, die nur deshalb nicht absurd ist, weil man sich daran gewöhnt hat. Aber wenn man drüber nachdenkt, was sagt denn das eigentlich aus? Wie ist die Rolle des Fußballs dahingehend zu sehen? Wir haben ja nicht nur den Leistungssport, wir haben auch den Breitensport. Wir haben eben die Vereine Makabis, die sich nicht sicher fühlen. Wir hatten auch offen gelebten Judenhass. Da gibt es einen sehr prominenten Fall, werde ich verlinken, in Berlin, der auch, ich glaube, auch mit einem Makabi-Verein passiert ist. Aber da gibt es ja antisemitische Handlungen. Und wir wissen ja auch, dass Stadion als Ort der Enthämmung, auch dort findet Antisemitismus statt. Es ist gut erforscht. Was muss da der Fußball dagegen tun? Und hat das vielleicht jetzt auch dann eine andere Dringlichkeit? Das ist das falsche Wort, weil ich möchte nicht abwerten, dass es vorher nicht dringend gewesen wäre. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, gerade wurde so die Herdplatte hochgedreht. Und alles wird extremer in der Meinungsäußerung.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also das ist auch meine Wahrnehmung. Ich glaube schon, dass der Fußball generell eine Rolle hat, was die Bekämpfung von Diskriminierung in der Gesellschaft betrifft. Es betrifft viele, viele Arten von Diskriminierung, in unterschiedlichen Arten und Weisen natürlich. Wenn wir spezifisch über den Antisemitismus in Deutschland sprechen würden, würde ich sagen, dass ich die Rolle der Vereine und des Fußballs wahrnehme als eine Rolle, die viel größer ist als nur, wenn es Krisen gibt. Ich nehme die Rolle des Fußballs so wahr, dass man... Also ich würde mir schon wünschen, dass man den Blick auf die jüdische Gemeinde und auf jüdisches Leben in Deutschland werfen würde, nicht nur am 27. Januar und wenn es im Nahost kracht. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass man tatsächlich dafür sorgen wird, dass man sehen wird, dass es auch modernes jüdisches Leben in Deutschland gibt. Und dass jüdischen Juden Deutschland... Es klingt krass, dass ich das sage, aber anscheinend ist das immer noch nötig im Jahr 23. Dass Jüdinnen und Juden in Deutschland genauso Menschen... Also, das sind Menschen genauso wie alle anderen. Die haben Hobbys, die haben alles, was andere Menschen haben. Nur diese Kleinigkeit mit der Zugehörigkeit einer jüdischen Gemeinde. Das ist ein Unterschied und das war es. Und diese Aufmerksamkeit zu geben, diese Legitimation von Seiten der Vereine, halte ich schon für sehr wichtig. Ich meine, in jeder Großstadt in Deutschland gibt es eine jüdische Gemeinde und auch in manchen nicht so großen Städten. Man könnte gerne miteinander zusammenarbeiten. Ich versuche das auch hier in Köln zu vermitteln, zwischen den beiden Seiten, und es gibt schon diese Kontakte hier in Köln, zwischen dem Vorstand des FC und der jüdischen Gemeinde in Köln, was mich sehr freut, obwohl es auch da viel zu tun gibt. Diese Sichtbarkeit, diese Normalisierung der Menschen, könnte so viel dazu beitragen, dass Diskriminierung im Fußball und auch in der Gesellschaft bekämpft wird. Wie gesagt, ich werde das nochmal erzählen. Viele Menschen aus meiner Kurve haben mir gesagt, als ich dich kennengelernt habe, du bist der erste jüdische Mensch, den wir kennenlernen. Mittlerweile spielt das eine Rolle in meinem Leben, dass ich jüdisch bin, aber wenn ich an jedem Wochenende, was weiß ich, wie viele Züge nehme, um den glorreichen FC Köln zu sehen, und dieselben Menschen sehe in der Kurve, die mir Hallo sagen, und wir supporten zusammen und trinken Bier zusammen, was weiß ich noch, das spielt eigentlich keine Rolle, dass ich jüdisch bin, solange dass man mich das nicht erinnert hat durch Antisemitismus. Ich bin ein bisschen glücklich, dass die Menschen persönlich in unserer Kurve wenig passiert, muss man fairerweise sagen. Das heißt nicht, dass alles perfekt ist. Es gibt bestimmte Störungen in der Fettkultur in Deutschland, das wissen wir alle. Aber trotzdem ist diese Sichtbarkeit von den Vereinen und auch von den Fanszenen, übrigens jede Fanszene hat offizielle Kanäle, sei es ein Fernsehen, ein Social-Media-Account, Veranstaltungen, die man macht. Das sind Sachen, die jede Fanszene hat. Und das zu nutzen, um Aufmerksamkeit auf jüdisches Leben und auf Diskriminierung generell aufmerksam zu machen, das halte ich für äußerst wichtig. Und das auch in normalen Zeiten und ohne Kriege. Manche Gruppen machen das schon, muss man sagen. Und auch manche Vereine machen das schon. Aber da gibt es immer noch sehr viel Redebedarf. Auch im Bereich Antisemitismus, aber auch in anderen Bereichen. Wie gesagt, das werde ich immer wieder erwähnen. Das Thema Sexismus in den Stadien ist ein Thema, worüber wir dringend sprechen müssen und ausführlich sprechen müssen. Sowohl von Seiten der Vereine als auch von den aktiven Ultragruppen, Fan-Gruppierungen, von der aktiven Fanszene. Das ist ein Thema, wo es auf jeden Fall sehr dringend ist. Ich meine, alle Diskriminierungen sind schlimm, haben ihre Besonderheiten und so weiter. Ich finde aber das Thema Sexismus in den Stadien so präsent, dass es einfach nicht zu ignorieren ist. Ich sage mal so, natürlich in einem Stadion von 50.000 Menschen wie das Möngerstadion für Stadion hier in Köln ist es statistisch betrachtet so, dass 30 Prozent von denen AfD wählen. Oder nicht möglich. Könnte sein. Durch als möglich, statistisch mega wahrscheinlich. Aber trotzdem gehe ich nicht ins Stadion und sehe vor mir irgendwelche Nazi-Fanen oder so. Das passiert auch nicht. Während Frauen ins Stadion gehen und in so vielen Spieltagen schlimme Erfahrungen machen mit Diskriminierung. Sei es durch Gesänge, sei es durch übergriffiges Verhalten und. Das ist auf jeden Fall, das muss auf jeden Fall ein größeres Thema werden, als das es gerade ist, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, das finde ich auch. Und gleichzeitig würde ich aber ganz gerne noch den Blick weg von den Stadien lenken, weil gerade wir, wir hängen halt so in dieser Welt drin und wir sind da auch viel unterwegs und so weiter, aber der größere Teil ist ja der Breitensport und der größere Teil ist ja eben das, was auf den Amateurplätzen passiert und wo eben gerade Spiele abgesagt werden nicht stattfinden und wo es auch schon vorher auch antisemitisch motivierte Straftaten gab, natürlich auch genügend rassistische und andere, aber eben auch Antisemitismus, der sich auf den Amateurplätzen bangebrochen hat. Und deswegen wollte ich diesen Schlenker noch machen, bevor wir dann ein letztes Mal dann nochmal auf den Profifußball zurückkommen und vielleicht auf andere Länder noch gucken und dann lass ich dich zur zweiten Halbzeit des Spiels gehen. Ich wollte kurz, das wird ein kurzer Monolog aus einer Handreichung der Stiftung Bergen-Belsen zitieren, sowohl zum einen eine Definition von Antisemitismus, weil nämlich immer gesagt wird, Mensch, wir müssen Antisemitismus mal neu definieren. Dachte ich ehrlich gesagt auch lang, auch bei vielen Podcasts, die ich jetzt gehört habe in den letzten Wochen. Jetzt habe ich diese Definition gelesen und dachte mir, okay, da fehlt mir eigentlich nichts. Also es gibt eine Arbeitsdefinition der International Holocaust Remembrance Alliance und die definiert Antisemitismus als eine bestimmte Wahrnehmung von Jüdinnen und Juden, die sich als Hass gegenüber Jüdinnen und Juden ausdrücken kann. Der Antisemitismus richtet sich in Wort oder Tat gegen jüdische oder nicht jüdische Einzelpersonen und oder deren Eigentum sowie gegen jüdische Gemeindeinstitutionen oder religiöse Einrichtungen. Darüber hinaus kann auch der Staat Israel, der dabei als jüdisches Kollektiv verstanden wird, Ziel solcher Angriffe sein. Das ist jetzt der Part, den die Bundesregierung übernommen hat 2017 als ihre Arbeitsdefinition von Antisemitismus. Interessant ist, glaube ich, noch der Nachsatz, den die International Holocaust Remembrance Alliance daran anfügt. Allerdings kann Kritik an Israel, die mit der an anderen Ländern vergleichbar ist, nicht als antisemitisch betrachtet werden. Also nicht jede Kritik an Israel muss antisemitisch sein. Und dann hören daraus verschiedene Formen von Antisemitismus erwachsen. Man unterscheidet dann zwischen klassischem, sekundären und israelbezogenen Antisemitismus. Wahrscheinlich sind die Details hier jetzt dann aber nicht so wichtig. Aber wichtig ist, wie wirkt sich das im im Fußball aus? Und auch dazu gibt es ja schon gute Forschung. Also ich werde auch verlinken, es gibt da eine Dissertation, ein Buch, in dem das aufgearbeitet wurde. Es gibt auch schon Aktionen von der DFL in Zusammenarbeit zum Beispiel mit Maccabi. Auch das werde ich alles verlinken. Also das Problembewusstsein ist schon da. Aber Antisemitismus im Fußball ist deswegen interessant. Zum einen, weil wir im Leistungs- oder im Bereich des Stadions eben diese enthemmte soziale Umgebung haben. Und zum anderen, weil wir bei Antisemitismus, wie bei eigentlich allen Diskriminierungsarten, ein Hellfeld haben und ein Dunkelfeld. Das Hellfeld, das sind die angezeigten Taten. Das ist schon gewachsen im Antisemitismus, zumindest jetzt in diesem Jahr. Und das Dunkelfeld ist aber noch ungleich viel höher. Und da gibt es verschiedene Formen, in denen sich das äußert. Das meiste sind tatsächlich Beleidigungen immer noch, zumindest ist das der Forschungsstand. Dann ist es von Spielern verbreiteter Antisemitismus. Ich glaube, das haben wir jetzt gerade rund um den 7. Oktober sehr viel gesehen. Und wir haben zum Teil auch ein diskriminierendes Verhalten ganzer Vereine. Das sind aber zum Glück die großen Ausnahmen, die es gibt. Jetzt gerade wurde erst wieder ein, jetzt habe ich gerade vergessen, der Fußballverband Sachsen hat doch gerade wieder den Nachfolgeverein dieser Ostalbien-Nazis wieder verboten. Da konnte man sowas auch sehen. Aber jetzt wollte ich noch kurz zu den Handlungsempfehlungen kommen. Ich werde die ganze Handreichung auch in den Show Notes verlinken. Das ist ein sehr lesenswertes PDF. Und ich finde es insofern interessant, weil ich danach nämlich gerne mit dir sprechen wollen würde, was in anderen liegen los ist und warum gerade viele Israelis, nachdem was du auch schon anderswo erzählt hast, sich neue Vereine suchen wollen. Die Handrei- die die Empfehlungen der Stiftung Bergen-Belsen sind, man soll Zeichen setzen, also das, was wir schon besprochen haben, öffentlich sich gegen Antisemitismus positionieren. Man soll aufklären, Schulung und Fortbildung auf allen wichtigen Schlüsselpositionen und Zielgruppen. Das beinhaltet zum Beispiel auch Ordner. Ich weiß, dass rund um die Schweigeminuten, zum Beispiel die DFL, auch Symbole der Hamas mitverbreitet hat, damit man eben darauf achten kann, dass eben nicht solche Symbole, die man vielleicht gar nicht kennt, im Stadion gezeigt werden. Antisemitismus systematisch erfassen und Betroffene unterstützen. Das Engagement gegen Antisemitismus stärken. Antisemitismus im sozialen Umfeld gemeinsam vor Ort bekämpfen. Das fand ich einen sehr interessanten Punkt, denn das meint, dass man niedrigschwellige Anlässe schafft, dort, wo man den Alltag der Beteiligten an denen anknüpfen kann. Also zum Beispiel, ich veranstalte eben ein Fußballturnier. Ich lade nicht zu der Lesung aus dem tollen Buch zu Antisemitismus im Fußball, sondern ich veranstalte ein Fußballturnier mit Beteiligten, Vereinsmitgliedern. Oder ich mache eine künstlerische Aktion mit Beteiligten, Vereinsmitgliedern oder vielleicht auch Nichtmitgliedern. Und in diesem Rahmen kläre ich über Antisemitismus auf. Die Unterschiedlichkeit der Zielgruppen im Blick behalten. Ganz wichtiger Punkt, es sind nämlich nicht nur die Fans, die manchmal antisemitisch sind. Lasst uns bitte auch auf die Haupttribünen gucken. Lasst uns bitte auch in die Logen gucken. Da gibt es also sehr, sehr viel noch zu tun. Begegnungen und Bildungsangebote sollen geschaffen werden, die lokalische jüdische Geschichte im Fußball erforschen. Meiner Meinung nach ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Instrument. Allein, wenn wir uns angucken, was da eben die Fans sehen, schon geleistet haben, die das getan haben. Also Eintracht Frankfurt hat da Untersuchungen zu gemacht. Die Südkurve München ist mit dem ganzen Gedenken an Kurt Landau immer so eins der Vorzeigebeispiele. Aber es gibt noch viele, viele andere im deutschen Fußball. Man soll die Prävention gegen Antisemitismus fachlich begleiten und eine Onlinepräsenz gegen Antisemitismus stärken. Das ist dann schon so eine ganz konkrete Plattform, die geschaffen wurde. Und dazu muss man wissen, inzwischen haben, das ging 2017 los und 2022 war es dann abgeschlossen, inzwischen gibt es in jedem Regionalverband, Fußballverband, gibt es Meldestellen gegen Diskriminierung und darunter fällt eben auch Antisemitismus. Auch die werde ich alle verlinken, da gibt es eine schöne Übersichtseite vom DFB. Und ich glaube eben gerade im Breitensport ist es eben wichtig, das zu wissen. Denn es ist schwierig bis wahrscheinlich manchmal unmöglich, sich alleine gegen Antisemitismus zu positionieren in einer vielleicht fremden Umgebung oder vielleicht auch in einer sehr vertrauten Umgebung, in der man sich aber in der Minderheit führt. Aber wir müssen als erster Schritt den Dunkelbereich verkleinern und den Hellbereich vergrößern. Antisemitismus muss erkennbar sein, sowie Diskriminierung jeder Art gemeldet werden müssen. Wir müssen uns des Problems bewusst werden. Das ist der erste Schritt, damit man etwas verbessern kann. Ich hoffe du verzeihst mir diesen langen Monolog. Ich hatte irgendwie das Gefühl, das hier noch los werden zu wollen. Wenn du dazu Gedanken hast, noch gerne. Ansonsten lass uns ins Ausland gucken. Du schüttelst den Kopf.
Alles gut, können wir auch gerne weiter machen.
Wir machen weiter. Was ist in der Premier League los? Warum ist es so, dass israelische Fußballfans sich ja verraten fühlen, nach den Schilderungen, die du mir im Vorgespräch erzählt hast, die ich anderswo auch gelesen habe, unter anderem von der Premier League, aber auch von anderen Ligen?
Ich glaube, das hat damit zu tun, das hat mit dieser Analyse von Juval Noah Harari zu tun. Ich glaube schon, dass es dieses Mal wenig Verständnis in Israel gibt für eine Position von, so nach dem Motto, wir sind beide Seiten. Es gibt dafür wenig bis gar kein Verständnis und viele, was heißt viele, die Premier League hat den Vereinen klar gesagt, also Israel-Fahnen, Palästina-Fahnen müssen raus aus den Stadien, die müssen rausbleiben. Wir bleiben da in der Mitte. Ich glaube, die Ausnahme ist Crystal Palace, Crystal Palace hat da ein sehr gutes Statement gemacht zu dem Thema, aber außerdem gab es so gut wie kein Premier League-Verein, der sich, ich sag mal, dem Geschmack der Israelis gut geäußert hat. Dazu kommen Geschichten wie die Geschichte mit dem FC Liverpool und der Fahne, der ermordeten und der Geschichte vom israelischen FC Chelsea-Fan-Club. Die Geschichte war so, der israelische FC Chelsea-Fan-Club hat eine Fahne, eine Art, da gibt es keine Zäune, aber so eine Fahne, die da in der Kurve hängt und diese Fahne hängt seit immer seit 2000 irgendwas, 12, 13, 14 irgendwas. Diese Fahne ist nichts politisches, das steht einfach Israeli Blues oder sowas mit zwei David Sternen an beiden Seiten. Eigentlich total easy. Der Verein hat denen gesagt, die Fahne muss runter. Es könnte eine Fahne da geben mit dem Namen Israeli Blues oder Israeli Chelsea Fans, aber David Sterne gehen nicht. Das ist uns zu politisch. Ich weiß nicht, was der aktuelle Standarddinger ist in dem Bereich, aber solche Vorfälle zeigen ganz genau, wie dieser Versuch der Premier League in der Mitte zu stehen, wie krass es scheitert. Weil wenn du nichts sagst, verlierst du nicht nur die eine Seite, du verlierst beide Seiten. Natürlich wollen auch Leute, die Pro-Palästinern sind, eine Art Statement sehen. Natürlich wollen das nicht nur Pro-Israelis oder Israelis an sich, aber diese Art von Umgang, so wir sitzen in der Mitte und wir machen nichts, oder wir verbieten den Fans und den Vereinen eine Seite zu nehmen, das hat nicht so gut geklappt, ich sage mal so, und das kommt nicht gut an, weder in Israel noch, soweit ich das beurteilen kann, auch in palästinensischen und pro-palästinensischen Kreisen. Und dazu kommt, dass es zum Beispiel Manor Solomon, also ein israelischer Spieler, der bei Tottenham spielt. Der postet seit einiger Zeit Informationen über den Krieg, über den Angriff vom 7. Oktober und was das mit Israel gemacht hat. Ich finde seine Inhalte harmlos, muss man sagen. Also es ist sehr mainstream in Israel, was er sagt. Er sagt nicht, es gibt schon Fußballer, die sich ekelhaft geäußert haben innerhalb von Israel. So nach dem Motto macht Gaza platt oder sowas. Aber Manor Solomon hat sich so geäußert, dass man sieht, der ist Israeli, der ist betroffen, der kennt betroffene Menschen, aber der hat die Linie nicht überschritten meiner Meinung nach und meiner Wahrnehmung nach. Wie gesagt, Klammer auf, ich bin da nicht objektiv, Klammer zu. Trotzdem bekommt er sehr viele Anfeindungen, viele Menschen auf Social Media fordern, dass Tottenham Manor Solomon bestraft dafür. Ja, also diese Geschichte, diesen Clash zwischen den zwei Seiten gibt es auf der Ebene. Ich glaube, dieser Clash ist bei keinem Verein so krass wie bei Celtic in Glasgow, wo es die Green Brigade gibt, eine Ultra-Gruppe, die sich pro-Palästinensisch positioniert, nicht nur pro-Palästinensisch, sondern auch diese Gruppe benutzt auch Symbolik von terroristischen Gruppen, muss gesagt werden. Es ist soweit interessant, weil es einen Verein gibt, mit einer sehr langen Geschichte von israelischen Spielern, die da gespielt haben. Nir Bitton, ein Spieler aus meiner Heimatstadt, hat da einige Jahre gespielt. Eyal Berkovich, eines der größten Namen des israelischen Fußballs aller Zeiten, hat einige Jahre bei Celtic gespielt. Lia Labada, eines der Stars von Celtic heutzutage ist Israeli und trotzdem musste man sehen, wie sie am 7. Oktober an Banner gehalten haben mit dem Satz so Victory to the Resistance oder so, als ob am 7. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es am 7. Oktober selbst war. So einen Satz, nachdem Menschen abgeschlachtet worden sind aus antisemitischen Gründen, zu halten, ist schon schwierig to say the least, ich sag mal so. Es gab da so eine Geschichte, so einen Konflikt zwischen dem Verein und der Green Brigade, wo die Mitglieder von denen so eine Art temporell Stadionverbot bekommen haben oder so, wegen irgendeinem Thema, was mit Sicherheit zu tun hat, aber die Green Brigade behauptet, dass das mit den Palästina-Protesten zu tun hat. Und da, glaube ich, merkt man schon, wie krass dieser Clash ist. Und jetzt, nachdem ich das beschrieben habe aus der Perspektive eines, ich sag mal Journalisten, möchte ich das beschreiben aus der Perspektive eines jüdischen Menschen. In Glasgow gibt es eine jüdische Gemeinde. Die jüdische Gemeinde in Glasgow ist auch nicht so klein. Ich meine die drittgrößte nach Manchester und London in Großbritannien. Und diese jüdische Gemeinde sieht wie eine sehr prominente Fangruppierung. An sehr vielen Stellen, nicht nur am 7. Oktober, Sprüche heraushaut, die super, super problematisch sind. Denn manchmal ja auch antisemitisch sind. Ein Satz wie Enzionism ist antisemitisch, bei Definition. Egal, wo ich mich positioniere in Sachen Zionismus. Und wie gesagt, ich bin am linken Rand. Das muss man ganz klar sagen. Also in Gesprächen mit meinen israelischen Freundinnen bekomme ich manchmal Namen, die ich nicht mal übersetzen würde, weil es so krass ist. Und trotzdem muss man sagen, Enzionism heißt, das Recht der Selbstbestimmung von jüdischen Menschen zu nehmen. Ihr habt es nicht verdient, weil Zionismus bedeutet jüdische Selbstbestimmung. Punkt. Das ist das, was das bedeutet. Und stellt euch mal vor, wie es sich anfühlt, als Jüdin oder Jude in Glasgow zu sein, aus Glasgow zu kommen, den Akzent sogar zu haben. Und du siehst, dass die wahrscheinlich prominenteste Fan-Gruppierung in der Stadt solche Wirtschaft heraushaut, und niemand sagt was. Wie fühlt es sich an? Und das ist schon sowas, worüber man sprechen muss, finde ich. Und tatsächlich war das auch Thema am 7. Oktober. Davor nicht. Also ich war auch selbst im Stadion bei Celtic. Einmal fand die Stimmung wirklich krass. Ich habe glaube ich kaum so eine Stimmung erlebt, was die Fußballstimmung angeht. Und prinzipiell definieren sie sich als antifaschistisch, machen sehr viel für Geflüchtetenrechte und so weiter. Alles gut und schön. Das geht aber mit Antisemitismus nicht an und das kann nicht zusammen gehen. Und wie gesagt, wie wir darüber gesprochen haben früher, das heißt nicht, dass man Israel nicht kritisieren darf. Auf gar keinen Fall. Ich würde sogar mehr sagen, das heißt nicht, dass man keine Palästinafahne halten darf. Auf jeden Fall darf das. Und das halte ich persönlich für wichtig. Das ist Sichtbarkeit für die Palästinien Kurs, wie man auf Englisch sagt. Und das halte ich auch für sehr wichtig. Aber wenn man vergisst, dass es auch auf der anderen Seite Menschen gibt, die seit Tausenden von Jahren verfolgt worden sind, dann fängt es an problematisch zu sein. Und bei Celtic ist das seit längerer Zeit auf jeden Fall so. Die Grenze wurde überschritten. Und das muss man auch ganz klar benennen, finde ich.
Ja, und vielleicht kann das ja auch tatsächlich so eines der Dinge sein, die man mitnehmen kann aus der aktuellen Situation, dass uns so schrecklich alles ist, was passiert ist. Aber es zwingt uns dazu, genauer hinzugucken und auch eigene Gewissheiten noch mal zu hinterfragen. Also jede Kritik an Katar und am Sponsoring des FC Bayern war meiner Meinung nach berechtigt. Wenn man jetzt aber weiß, dass Katar einer der Hauptfinanziellsten der Hamas ist, zusammen mit dem Iran, dann bekommt das noch mal eine ganz andere Qualität. Und dann muss man das noch mal neu besprechen. Genauso wie eben jetzt hier mit der Green Brigade bei Celtic Glasgow, wo ich auch viele Menschen kenne, die eben gerade wegen des Einsatzes für Geflüchtete und so weiter, weil sie aus einem linken Spektrum kommen, da große Sympathien für haben. Und gleichzeitig habe ich das auch nicht gesehen, diesen Antisemitismus. Ich sehe hier Bilder der PFLP, die beim Spiel gegen Atletico Madrid in der Champions League gezeigt wurde. Das wird nicht zum ersten Mal gewesen sein, da diese Fahne war. Ich wusste nicht, was sie bedeutet, ich habe nicht hingesehen. Ich habe Antisemitismus auch im linken Spektrum nicht so sehr vermutet, wie er da ganz offensichtlich grassiert, so wie ich es jetzt aktuell feststelle. Und genauso auch mit dem, was du über England erzählt hast. Bei England gibt es ja gleich noch zwei Aspekte, die interessant sind beim Verhalten der Premier League. Das eine ist, England ist die Besatzungsmacht, die sich dann zurückgezogen hat. Und letztlich, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, England ist schuld, aber die Beziehung zwischen England und allen Menschen, die in dieser Region wohnen, ist nun nochmal eine ganz besondere. Da kann man sich auch nochmal einlesen, wenn ein das interessiert. Und das zweite ist, ich zumindest komme nicht um den Fakt herum, du hast es vorhin angedeutet. Wir haben in Deutschland noch einige Mitglieder geführte Vereine, aber sie sind allesamt, fast allesamt nicht in der Hand von ausländischen Investoren. Bei der Premier League komme ich nicht an dem Fakt vorbei, dass da ganze Scheichtümer mit eingebunden sind, dass da auch Saudi-Arabien jetzt bei Newcaste mit dabei ist. Da kann man jetzt auch die Gegenargumentation fahren. Es gibt, ja, Anlass zur Vermutung ist, offenbar standen ja Israel und Saudi-Arabien relativ kurz vor einer Art Friedensabkommen, was auch historisch gewesen wäre. Wer weiß, welche Rolle das bei den Taten der Hamas gespielt hat. Wir müssen da aber gar nicht zu sehr ins Detail zu gehen, um einfach zu erkennen, auch dahingehend müssen wir eben diese Struktur dieser Liga hinterfragen und müssen uns eben dann auch die Frage stellen, ich meine, wir, du und ich, wir werden uns nicht die Premier League verändern, dir würde das zwar sehr viel bedeuten, weil du dann United retten könntest, vielleicht würden da mal wieder positive Dinge passieren, aber wir gestalten ja, wie wir hier in Deutschland leben und wie wir hier in Deutschland über den Fußball sprechen und den Fußball gestalten. Und ich glaube, das kann vielleicht so, ja, Anlass dafür sein, eben Dinge zu hinterfragen, Dinge zu erkennen und dann zu überlegen, was müssen wir jetzt in Deutschland dann bewahren, was müssen wir vielleicht verändern, wo müssen wir eigene Positionen noch mal hinterfragen, damit so zynisch das klingt, aber aus diesen schlechten dann doch noch etwas Gutes wird, dass nie das Schlechte aufwiegen kann. Also ich möchte das auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie relativieren, aber ich glaube, du weißt, was ich meine. Wir müssen ja irgendwie nach vorne gehen und schauen. Und ich glaube, das wäre so das, was ich mir erhoffen würde aus diesem schrecklichen Anlass, dass daraus entwächst.
Auf jeden Fall. Also ich finde schon, dass man das nicht vergessen darf, dass es auch einen Tag nach dem Krieg gibt. Und egal, wie krass Menschen gerade sich miteinander streiten oder was weiß ich, es gibt auch einen Tag danach. Und den Tag danach wird ganz, ganz entscheidend sein in Sachen Zukunftsgestaltung, sowohl im Nahen Osten als auch hier in Deutschland. Und das ist manchmal aus der Emotion heraus ganz, ganz schwer, sich daran zu erinnern. Ich spreche auch über mich selbst, aber es ist entscheidend richtig. Also es ist unfassbar wichtig zu wissen, dass dieser Krieg irgendwann mal vorbei sein wird. Und wir werden einen Umgang finden. Wir werden einen Umgang miteinander finden. Sei es innerhalb der deutschen Gesellschaft zwischen Leuten, die pro Israel sind und Leuten, die pro Palästina sind. Sei es zwischen Leuten, die jüdisch und muslimisch sind. Was weiß ich, es gibt so viele Facetten. Und ich finde es nur richtig und wichtig, Menschen daran zu erinnern, diesen Tag nicht aus der Sicht zu verlieren. Die harte Arbeit, wie wir dann anfangen, finde ich. Die harte Arbeit von Strukturen zu entwickeln und Konzepte zu entwickeln, wie man miteinander leben könnte, sowohl hier als auch da. Wie man miteinander klarkommen könnte und wie man in vielen Situationen im Leben auch kooperieren könnte. Ich meine, es gab einige Kooperationen zwischen muslimischen Teilen der deutschen Gesellschaft und der jüdischen Gemeinde in Deutschland. Es ist nicht so, dass es überhaupt nicht passiert ist. Präzidenten gibt es schon. Und da ist halt die Hoffnung, dass dieser schreckliche Krieg dazu führen wird, dass Menschen verstehen werden, was Krieg bedeutet. Ein Krieg ist kein Fußballspiel. Beim Krieg gibt es immer eine graue Zone. Es gibt immer, wie du schon früher gesagt hast, es gibt keine Seite, die hier 100 Prozent richtig ist. Das wäre eine krasse Vereinfachung des Konflikts. Es gibt zwei Seiten, bei denen es Sachen zu kritisieren gibt, Sachen, die nicht zu kritisieren gibt. Und zwei Seiten, die irgendwie miteinander leben müssten, am Tag nach dem Krieg. Und das gilt auch für Deutschland. Und solange das Menschen diesen Tag im Kopf hätten, werden wir viel mehr davon gewinnen als von noch einer Diskussion, nur mal sieben Millionen zum Thema Konflikt. Ich habe mich ein bisschen verzandert mit der Wortwahl. Aber das Thema Konflikt wird sehr, sehr oft diskutiert. Und es führt tatsächlich in der Heat of the moment, also in der Moment, in der alle emotional involviert sind und wo alle eine klare Position haben und alle die Expertise haben und alle die ganze Welt kennen auf einmal. Das bringt im Endeffekt nichts. Vor allem aus der nicht betroffenen Perspektive, muss man sagen. Und das ist halt meine eher naive Hoffnung, aber trotzdem meine Hoffnung.
Aber siehst du, Felix, wir kommen beide nicht aus einer Haut. Haben da nicht gerade der Sohn eines Rabbinas und der Sohn von zwei Pfarrern, haben wir nicht gerade unsere Schlusspredigt gehalten? Ein bisschen fühlt es sich so an.
Das könnte man so formulieren.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass meine Eltern diese Folge hören und sie werden mir wahrscheinlich Feedback geben. Und meine Freunde haben schon früh gesagt, ich habe Freunde aus meiner Heimat, wenn manche Folgen von F-Leben gehört haben, dann kam nur die Reaktion, ah, da kam wieder der Prediger in dir raus. Und ich fand es natürlich nicht so toll, wenn sie das gesagt haben. Aber sie hatten dann doch irgendwie recht. Felix, wie soll ich dir danken? Das war für uns beide, glaube ich, sehr intensiv, auch in der Vorbereitung. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir ging. Ich hatte eine ungewöhnlich hohe Anspannung heute in mir vor dieser Sendung, obwohl diese Sendung irgendwie 1000 ist für den Rasenfunk umso mehr. Danke, dass du mit dabei warst und dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast.
Danke dir für die Zeit und die sehr gute Vorbereitung, die du gemacht hast. Ich fand es wirklich sehr, sehr intensiv. So intensiv, dass ich das Drittligaspiel von Victoria Köhne gegen Dinamo Dresden heute Abend verpasst habe.
Was? Ich dachte, du kannst jetzt noch zur zweiten Halbzeit.
Aber es hat sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt, es war eine megagute Diskussion. Und ich hoffe, dass die Türinnen und Tür irgendwie davon was nehmen können. Und ja, ansonsten sehen wir uns hoffentlich in besseren Zeiten nun sprechen über irgendwelche Fan-Gruppierungen, die eine Aktion getan haben oder eine Fahne geklaut haben. Und das wäre unsere Sorgen im Leben, ich sag mal so.
Aber absolut dein Wort in jedes Ohr. Gibt es noch irgendwelche, ich möchte gleich noch ein paar Podcast-Empfehlungen machen. Hast du auch etwas, wo du sagst, das würdest du jetzt den Hörern und Hörern noch empfehlen?
Der Podcast, den ich empfehlen würde, es hat nichts mit dem Thema zu tun, muss man sagen. Aber ich habe in den letzten Monaten den Podcast Legende Verloren entdeckt über die Geschichte des Frauenfußballs. Ich weiß nicht, ob es schon erwähnt worden ist in dem Zusammenhang, aber ich würde es schon gerne erwähnen. Ich lerne sehr, sehr viel von deren Arbeit und ich finde es sehr, sehr empfehlenswert, das zu hören und sich immer mehr nicht nur mit dem Fußball der Frauen von heutzutage auseinanderzusetzen, sondern auch mit den Traditionen, die sich da entwickelt haben und mit der Geschichte des Spiels einfach. Ich finde, die machen da großartige, wichtige Arbeit für den Fußball in Deutschland im Allgemeinen. Das wäre mein Schlusswort für heute, glaube ich.
Okay, dann bin ich jetzt der Spielverderber, der nicht-Fußball-Podcast empfiehlt. Aber ich habe viele Sendungen gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich bin in meinem Podcastbereich geblieben, habe mich jetzt nicht in fremde Podcastreihen gehört. Ich möchte euch folgende Sendungen empfehlen zur Thematik in dieser absteigenden Reihenfolge. Die 29er habe ich schon mal empfohlen. Die haben drei Stunden, 50 Minuten wirklich sehr differenziert über sehr viele Aspekte gesprochen. Da habe ich auch dieses Harari-Zitat zum ersten Mal gehört. Dann hat Piraten-Sender Powerplay. Die haben zwei Sendungen gemacht, einmal was jetzt mit Israel passiert, mit Richard C. Schneider und was jetzt mit Gaza passiert, mit Tom Khaled. Beide Sendungen kann ich euch sehr empfehlen. Außerdem die Folgesendung, das größte Dilemma der Welt. Und der Aufwachen-Podcast hat in seiner aktuellen Folge herausgearbeitet, warum man sich vielleicht besser aktuell leider nicht über die ARD informiert, zumindest nicht über Tagesschau und Tagesthemen. Da sind einige Lücken in der Berichterstattung. Das sind jetzt von den Sendungen, die ich gehört habe, die ich euch herausstellen würde. Es wird umfangreiche Show Notes zu dieser Sendung geben, ganz, ganz viele Links. Da werden auch diese Podcasts mit drin sein. Und ihr werdet sehen, wo ihr Felix folgen könnt. Bitte tut das. Felix, vielen Dank dir nochmal.
Und ich werde nur noch ein Wort sagen, wenn ich verstehe, dass das Thema kompliziert ist und das Thema aufgeladen ist. Wenn jemand irgendwelche Fragen hat, Anregungen, wie gesagt, ich bin auch sehr, sehr offen für konstruktive Kritik. Und wenn es darum geht, eine Diskussion darauf zu entwickeln, mega gerne. Ich bitte aber um Verständnis, dass meine Wortwahl manchmal ein bisschen komisch ist durch die Tatsache, dass Deutsch meine dritte Sprache ist.
Das ist ja eh schon krass.
Sonst wirklich immer super gerne, sei es Instagram, Twitter, Blue Sky, wo auch immer. Ich bin tatsächlich da und ich freue mich über jede Anregung. Danke dir, Max, für die Zeit und danke euch, liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, dass ihr das zugehört habt.
Dann nimmt er mir einfach meine Abmoderation weg. Aber das wollte ich natürlich auch noch sagen. Gebt uns Feedback auch unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Das könnt ihr diskutieren. Ich glaube, gerade für längere Beiträge ist das dann ein guter Ort. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke, dass ihr durch eure Unterstützung solche Sendungen wie diese hier möglich macht.rasenfunk.de ist die Adresse, wo ihr alles findet zum Rasenfunk. Ganz viele andere Sendungen auch noch. Dann bin ich sehr gespannt auf die sich an diese Sendung anschließende Diskussionen. Danke, dass ihr zugehört habt. Danke dir, Felix. Bleibt gesund, ihr alle.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.